Une fois qu'ils étaient
idoles plus grandes que nature
créé pour
divertir les enfants
et ont été licenciés
par le monde adulte.
Mais dans le nouveau
millénaire,
personnages créés sur
il y a un demi-siècle
ont refait surface pour dominer
le box-office dans le monde entier.
C'est l'histoire
de la façon dont les super-héros
avoir réussi
transitionné
de la page de la bande dessinée
à l'écran d'argent
et conquis
la culture populaire...
Quoi
les bandes dessinées avaient plus de films
est-ce qu'ils étaient en avance
du public.
Ils étaient
un rugueux et prêt
bon marché pour produire le milieu.
Et Hollywood
c'est juste maintenant,
50, 60 ans plus tard
rattraper.
Il y a
toujours un attrait pour les personnages
un public
peuvent se voir dans
mais peut voir
ce qu'ils aimeraient pouvoir faire
et ne peut tout simplement pas.
Qu'ils peuvent voler.
Qu'ils peuvent
balancer des toiles.
battre un tyran.
Et il y a juste
quelque chose d'intrinsèquement cool
et faisant appel à
super-héros qui font ça.
Cela explose maintenant.
C'est le grand public.
Été 1989.
Un nouveau phénomène
a surgi
qui alimente l'imagination de
publics à travers le monde.
Depuis le
premiers rapports
qu'une nouvelle fonctionnalité de Batman
le film était imminent,
dirigé par un jeune réalisateur
Tim Burton,
anticipation
a été élevé.
Et maintenant, alors que le film se prépare
pour diffusion générale,
dans les rues
des villes du monde
sa présence est impossible
ignorer.
Ce phénomène est rapidement
appelé "Batmanie".
C'était
si étranger et si fou
et l'attente
était si élevé.
Je me souviens quand j'étais enfant
et la bande-annonce est sortie.
je me souviens avoir été
avec tous mes amis
et nous venons de regarder
l'un l'autre.
Nous avons payé pour aller au théâtre
juste pour voir la bande annonce
Parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'Internet.
-Vicki Vale.
- Bruce Wayne.
Et que fais-tu dans la vie ?
Nous nous sommes juste assis là
avec nos bouches ouvertes.
Quelle réalité alternative
me suis-je réveillé dans
où je regarde une bande-annonce
pour un film Batman?
Et bien que le
centre de cette hystérie
était un nouveau long métrage,
La version
intérêt éveillé
dans le personnage
de Batman lui-même
et a contribué à revitaliser
le moyen
d'où il
avait émergé -
la bande dessinée.
Quand Tim
Batman de Burton est sorti
les gens étaient définitivement
lire des bandes dessinées,
mais c'était pas super cool
lire des bandes dessinées.
Mais quand ce film est sorti
et la commercialisation a commencé
et tu venais de
ce symbole de chauve-souris
ça avait l'air tellement cool.
Il ne s'agissait pas des acteurs.
C'était à peu près le symbole
et le personnage.
Le film était
publié pour coïncider
avec le 50e anniversaire de
son personnage principal emblématique,
et pendant Batman
durée de vie d'un demi-siècle,
bandes dessinées,
et les super-héros représentés
dans leurs pages,
avait dérivé dans et hors
de la conscience dominante.
Mais ils n'avaient jamais été
'cool' avant,
et de la
tout début
de l'américain
industrie de la bande dessinée
à la fin des années 1930,
ils avaient toujours
été licencié
comme divertissement jetable
pour les enfants.
C'était un
l'industrie présentée aux enfants.
Ils étaient bon marché.
Ils coûtent un sou.
Ils étaient vendus dans les pharmacies
et les confiseries.
Les enfants se montreraient
et mettraient leur centime,
leurs 20, 30 centimes.
Ils les roulaient,
collez-les dans leur poche arrière.
Peut-être qu'ils les échangeraient
avec des amis.
Ils étaient essentiellement
quelque chose que tu as acheté
avec un soda
et un paquet de chewing-gum.
Vous les avez stockés
sous ton lit.
Et quand tu as grandi
et tu avais 16 ans
vous ne les relisez plus jamais.
Mais
des pages
de ceux-ci
livres d'images pour enfants
émergeraient des héros qui ont
perduré jusqu'à nos jours.
Bien que les années de formation
de l'industrie se concentraient
en bandes courtes
et personnages de comédie,
à la fin des années 1930
deux de ses icônes déterminantes
ont été développés par New
L'éditeur York DC comics.
Bandes dessinées en action
Numéro un,
duo Jerry Siegel
et Joe Shuster
présenté Superman,
et en réponse
l'année suivante
Bob Kane et Bill Finger
a créé Batman.
Le tout-puissant
fils de Krypton
et le noir
Chevalier détective
sont devenus des archétypes pour tous
des super-héros
qui a suivi
dans leur sillage.
Quand Superman a été créé
ils ont créé un super-héros
d'une autre planète
qui est en effet presque
comme un dieu, mais non.
Il veut vraiment
être un homme.
être Clark Kent.
Il est la fin du spectre.
Tous les super-héros
sont moins que lui.
Batman n'est pas
un super-héros du tout.
Il porte juste un costume.
Batman est un homme ordinaire
qui s'est formé
devenir un grand détective
et un grand athlète.
Tous les autres comiques
super-héros du livre
mentir entre
ces deux personnages.
Ce sont les alpha
et oméga de notre industrie.
Un immédiat
succès auprès des jeunes lecteurs,
les éditeurs de bandes dessinées se sont précipités
développer de nouveaux super-héros
capitaliser sur le succès
de Superman et Batman.
Et ce boom créatif
s'est produit
tout comme une autre industrie
appréciait aussi
un regain d'intérêt
du jeune public.
Avec l'avènement du son
au cinéma,
Hollywood était en plein essor,
et les sociétés cinématographiques étaient
à la recherche de nouveau matériel
apporter à la
écran d'argent.
Avec leur plus grand que nature
personnages
et leur dynamique
Style visuel,
bandes dessinées représentées
une compatibilité instantanée
Forme d'art.
La bande dessinée à son
les meilleurs sont très cinématographiques.
Si vous regardez les storyboards
pour les films,
ce sont des pages de bandes dessinées.
Le plus proche
vous pouvez obtenir des bandes dessinées
à l'ambiance d'un film
et le déroulement d'un film
mieux ils sont.
Pour ne pas dire qu'un médium
est supérieur à l'autre.
Dans le
fin des années 30, début des années 40
quand les gens allaient au cinéma
c'était une affaire de toute la journée.
Vous auriez une image 'A',
vous auriez une image 'B',
vous auriez des dessins animés,
courts métrages, actualités.
Et vraiment loin sur la facture
était quelque chose appelé une série.
Éclair!
Ne tirez pas.
Sauve-toi, Flash.
Vous serez réduit en cendres.
Je te libère d'abord.
Il a choisi sa propre mort !
Ces
étaient les mangeurs de fond
pour la plupart des enfants
qui a vu les matinées du samedi.
Ils pourraient être
18 minutes,
ils étaient noirs et blancs,
ils ont été filmés
sur un petit budget absolu.
Ils ont commencé
avec les westerns.
Flash Gordon s'est glissé dans
à la fin des années 30
et quelqu'un a dépensé
un supplément de 1,50 $.
Les super-héros commencent à apparaître sur le
scène, '38, '39, '40,
donc c'était une évidence
pour essayer de les faire entrer
à ces films.
C'était
assez logique ça
une fois les super-héros de bande dessinée
est devenu
très populaire et visible
qu'ils feraient
la transition
ou tenter de faire
le passage à l'écran,
au cinéma.
Bob Kane, Bill Finger
ont été très influencés
par le citoyen Kane.
Jerry Robinson,
un des premiers artistes de Batman,
pris beaucoup d'images de
expressionniste allemand
films
et mettez ça dans Batman.
Quand j'étais petit,
J'ai regardé les séries Batman,
qui étaient terribles.
J'ai regardé le Superman
des feuilletons qui étaient super.
J'ai regardé tout ça
quand j'allais au cinéma
avec mes amis.
Ce n'était donc pas seulement
les bandes dessinées
nous avions enroulé
dans notre poche arrière.
Ce sont les feuilletons qui
nous avons vu samedi matin
avec les dessins animés.
Ces choses faisaient partie
d'un processus évolutif
qui a été coupé en 1953.
Tout comme Superman
diplômé des séries
à un nom familier par le biais d'un
émission de télévision à succès,
les bandes dessinées sont tombées
sous le regard scrutateur
des censeurs américains.
En tant que préoccupations nationales
sur la délinquance juvénile
atteint son paroxysme,
les bandes dessinées ont été distinguées
comme une mauvaise influence
sur les jeunes,
esprits impressionnables.
Après être entré
le courant dominant momentanément,
les super-héros étaient à nouveau
jeté dans l'obscurité.
Et ici ils sont restés
jusqu'à ce que le monde soit transformé
à l'envers dans les années 1960.
Comme les Beatles l'ont annoncé
l'aube d'un vibrant,
la culture populaire portée par les jeunes,
dans ce nouveau monde courageux
vint le retour sur les écrans de
le détective Dark Knight.
Et contrairement
son incarnation passée
dans les séries cinématographiques,
ce Batman est devenu
une sensation internationale.
Oui, commissaire.
Une terrible nouvelle. Catwoman est
à nouveau à l'affût.
Nous sommes en route.
Aux Batpoles.
Quand Batman est apparu
à la télévision américaine
en 1966,
personne n'avait vraiment
vu Batman.
Il y avait un
quelques séries
mais c'était une pleine couleur
plusieurs millions de dollars
épisode télévisé bihebdomadaire.
Et la grande chose que les gens
oubliez le '66 Batman
est-ce qu'il a été montré
à 7h30 du soir
et c'était le premier
chose de super-héros, chose médiatique
jamais lancé à la fois
quand les adultes pouvaient aussi le regarder.
Batman est devenu
un phénomène adulte.
Il a explosé ce monde
de l'attirail de chauve-souris
et marchandises de chauve-souris.
je me risquerais à dire
que la Batmobile
de la série 1966-67
est probablement encore
la voiture la plus reconnaissable
dans l'histoire américaine.
Comme je le pensais, elle est minée
la route avec des explosifs.
Pas étonnant que tu m'ai eu
mettre l'armure de chauve-souris.
Mon Dieu, tu penses vraiment
de tout, Batman.
Qu'est ce que c'est?
Bien que l'armure de chauve-souris
protégé notre voiture...
Dans les années 1960,
vous avez eu l'émission télévisée Batman
qui a eu beaucoup de succès,
mais tout était question de camp.
Il marchait sur cette ligne
entre d'une part
les enfants étaient contents
voir leur héros à la télé
et prenait généralement
les aventures à leur valeur nominale,
mais, bien sûr, les adultes étaient
le regarder et en rire
et par implication rire
à la bande dessinée
super-héros en général.
Vous avez, bande de voleurs !
Un mouvement et vous êtes un duo mort.
Sacré piège à chauve-souris!
Battons-nous pour nous en sortir.
C'était
destiné à être campy.
Il était destiné
être une satire.
L'écriture du spectacle
était stupide et merveilleux
en même temps. C'était
juste une chose fantastique.
Ce n'était pas Batman
mais c'était une bonne satire.
C'était inspirant
parce que tu pourrais
puis regarde-le et dis,
"Ce n'est pas Batman.
Mais au moins
nous faisons des bandes dessinées.
Ça commence, d'accord."
Qui avait la prévoyance
savoir que ça commence?
Personne. Pas vraiment.
Mais maintenant nous pouvons regarder en arrière
dessus et dire,
"Oui, ça commence."
Alors que ce pop art
la parodie propulsait Batman
au coeur même de
la révolution culturelle des années 60,
dans le monde de la bande dessinée,
une nouvelle force était
transformer l'industrie
et réécrire les règles -
Merveille.
Bien que la société
avait ses origines
dans le boom de la bande dessinée
de la fin des années 1930,
c'était dans les années 1960
qu'il a vraiment fait
sa présence ressentie,
alimenté par
la conduite remarquable
d'écrivain et d'éditeur,
Stan Lee.
Dans une vague de
inspiration,
il a créé une richesse
de super-héros très modernes
qui a prouvé
avoir un attrait durable.
Hulk,
Spiderman, Daredevil,
Les Vengeurs, Iron Man -
ce sont les cadres
de grands personnages Marvel
qu'il a créé
avec Jack Kirby et Steve Ditko
Presque toute la nuit.
Il les a tous créés à l'intérieur
deux ans, ce qui est étonnant.
Et ce que Stan Lee a fait était
pour prendre ces geeks costumés,
ces cinglés, et placez-les
a New York,
et il pourrait apporter
tensions des années 1960,
radiation,
communisme, aliénation,
et il les a simplement faites
psychologique et humain.
Chaque héros Marvel,
aussi ridicule soit-il,
essayé d'avoir une base
dans une réalité que le public
pouvait comprendre.
je n'avais aucun intérêt
dans la vie de Clark Kent,
ou la vie de Superman.
Bruce Wayne était
bien au-delà de la réalité
je voyais autour de moi
aussi réaliste que Donald Trump.
C'était ça qui était cool
à propos de Spider-Man,
à propos de Peter Parker.
C'est un high
étudiant
et il était
un lycéen
dans un sens
qui a séduit les geeks -
il portait une cravate,
un gilet sans manches.
Qui a frappé douloureusement
près de la maison.
Ces personnages Marvel
est vite devenu
noms de famille,
rapidement transféré
de la page de la bande dessinée
au poste de télévision
grâce au succès
série de dessins animés.
Leur appel
était en grande partie confiné
au marché des jeunes,
cependant,
et les super-héros ont continué
être reconnu
comme pour les enfants
divertissement.
Cela modifierait
dans la décennie suivante.
Avec un changement
en propriété,
Les bandes dessinées de DC avaient été apportées
dans Warner Communications,
un vaste groupe de médias
avec un puissant
bras de production cinématographique.
Cela a conduit, en 1978,
au premier
blockbuster de super-héros,
mettant en vedette le pionnier de DC
Homme d'acier...
Alors que
Marvel surpassait DC
dans les bandes dessinées
c'était tout le contraire
au cinéma
parce que DC avait
les personnages les plus reconnaissables
pour un public de masse.
Alors quand le Christopher Reeve
Le film Superman est sorti
c'était évidemment
un énorme succès.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Facile, mademoiselle. Je vous ai.
Vous... Vous m'avez ?
Qui t'a ?!
Il est venu
à un moment particulier
quand les grands événements cinématographiques
étaient soudainement très attrayants
aux auditoires.
L'idée de faire la queue
autour du bloc,
d'où le nom de "blockbuster",
était quelque chose qui soudainement
est devenu très excitant pour les gens.
Et je pense qu'il était évidemment
une propriété très connue,
une propriété très réputée,
probablement le plus célèbre.
Et, bien sûr,
c'est un film de famille,
mais ce n'est pas un
film pour enfant.
Certainement
le premier et le deuxième
Films de Superman
de la fin des années 70
avec Christopher Reeve,
réalisé par Richard Donner
puis Richard Lester.
Ils sont pour moi
conte mythique américain.
Ils déroulent son origine.
Superman 2
est une fantastique histoire grecque
où il doit abandonner
ses pouvoirs pour être heureux
ou va-t-il être malheureux
et sauver le monde ?
C'est un truc mythique.
Avec un casting de stars
et le plus gros budget de tous les temps
consacré à un long métrage,
Superman et Superman II
ont été abattus dos à dos
et libéré
à d'énormes commerciaux
et succès critique.
Et malgré les limites
d'effets visuels à l'époque,
comme l'affiche originale du film
s'est exclamé,
il a fait croire au public
qu'un homme pouvait voler.
Le défi
à toute adaptation de bande dessinée
le rend réaliste.
Pour tout film de science-fiction,
pour tout film de genre
qui implique de la fantaisie
ou ces éléments,
c'est la suspension volontaire
d'incrédulité.
Si nous ne pouvons pas croire que
Christopher Reeve volait
dans le premier Supermanfilm,
si nous ne pouvons pas croire que ces
les personnages ont ces pouvoirs.
Mais je pense que plus important encore,
si nous ne pouvons pas croire
que l'acteur
jouer il croit
qu'ils tirent optique
des rayons hors de leurs yeux
ou lecture
les pensées des autres,
ou téléportation
sur de grandes distances
ça ne va pas se vendre
au public.
Mais Superman
n'a pas lancé de tendance
et dans son sillage
seulement une poignée de super-héros
les adaptations ont suivi.
Dans le monde de la bande dessinée, cependant,
les choses changeaient.
Ce n'était nulle part
plus apparent
que dans les pages
de "Batman",
un héros qui avait subi
une refonte radicale
depuis la caricature du camp
de la série télé des années 60...
D'abord,
qui a eu un grand impact
sur les ventes de bandes dessinées de Batman.
Ils ont vraiment dopé.
Mais ils ont commencé à suivre
l'émission de télévision un peu.
Puis quand la télé s'est écrasée
et les cotes ont chuté,
puis il a été annulé,
les bandes dessinées de Batman
ont été laissés dans ce
'Qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant?'
Heureusement, je pense
l'écrivain Denny O'Neil
et Neal Adams a pris
une approche très différente.
Ils ont sorti Batman de
l'émission de télévision complètement.
Ils
est retourné au Batman
qui est apparu
en 1939, 1940.
Et puis j'ai eu une sorte de
blanchi à la chaux.
C'était un sombre vengeur
qui n'existait que la nuit.
Il représentait la vengeance.
Il représentait
châtiment.
Il a mené une vie très dure.
Et vous aviez ces
aventures solo de Batman
que Frank Miller a repris
au début des années 1980 et a tourné
dans la saga Dark Knight.
Et c'était ça
vision plus sombre de Batman
ça tirerait
super-héros
dans un monde bien plus granuleux
Dans les années 1980.
Avec la sortie
de Frank Miller
roman graphique fondateur
Le retour du chevalier noir et
Blague meurtrière d'Allan Moore,
la bande dessinée avec succès
a transcendé ses racines
comme divertissement pour enfants,
et est devenu plus adulte,
plus sombre
et souvent plus violent.
En février 1989,
tout comme les remorques
a commencé à circuler
pour la suite
long métrage,
gros titres à travers l'Amérique
étaient concentrés
sur la bande dessinée Batman elle-même,
et une histoire en quatre numéros
qui s'est terminé
avec le meurtre de Robin.
Tu es sur ce chemin
où Batman est en quelque sorte
un personnage phare.
Toutes les bandes dessinées deviennent
aussi mature que Batman,
ou ils deviennent
aussi sombre que Batman.
Batmangenre de
ouvre la voie.
Evidemment quand Tim Burton
va faire le personnage,
et le scénariste
est assigné
et tout le reste,
ils regardent
à la BD actuelle
donc le personnage
devenait sombre.
Et puis tu ajoutes
Tim Burton au mix
et vous obtenez
ce que Tim Burton apporte
et c'est comme ça que tu finis
avec ce film.
Autant que
la folie Batman de 1989
a été motivé par la publicité,
le film lui-même
a été commercialisé
comme idée originale
du réalisateur Tim Burton,
et c'était la clé
à son appel.
Un cinéaste doué
avec une vision particulière,
il a signalé un
nouveau Hollywood
c'était jeune,
alternatif et moderne.
Ah!
de Tim Burton
Batman était personnel.
Il a un super look.
Il a
un grand sens des choses.
C'était invitant
un talent créatif
dans le domaine
de faire des bandes dessinées.
Il n'aurait pas pu le faire
de toute autre manière s'il essayait.
Ne me tuez pas.
Ne me tue pas, mec.
Ne me tue pas, mec !
Je ne vais pas te tuer.
Je veux que tu me rendes un service.
je veux que tu dises
tous vos amis autour de moi.
Qui es-tu?
Je suis Batman.
Que Tim
Burton a fait dans son film était
il l'a gardé centré
dans l'univers de Tim Burton.
Si vous regardez
sa longue liste de films
depuis
Un cauchemar avant Noël
au jus de coléoptère
aux mains d'Edward Scissor
il y a une cohérence
à tous les niveaux.
Il a un ADN Tim Burton.
Il a pu faire venir
les éléments de Batman
que les gens ont vraiment compris
comme Batman.
Gotham était sombre.
Il y avait un élément de danger
c'était omniprésent
que quelqu'un comme Batman
mener une guerre contre le crime.
Il a eu
toutes les bonnes choses
tout en mettant
l'empreinte Tim Burton dessus.
Pourtant, le film n'était pas
sans controverse.
Quand il avait
annoncé initialement,
les fans de bandes dessinées étaient
outré par le casting
de Michael Keaton
dans le rôle principal,
un acteur plus associé
avec la comédie que le drame.
Pourtant il a prouvé
un choix inspiré.
Avec Jack Nicholson
performance de vol de scène
en tant que Joker,
Kim Basinger devient
un nom familier
comme intérêt amoureux
Vicky Vale
et un album de bande son
avec
tout nouveau matériel de Prince,
Batman non seulement revitalisé
films de super-héros,
mais réécrit le livre de règles
comment lancer avec succès
une franchise à succès.
C'était le premier
superproduction pré-ordonnée
de l'âge moderne.
C'était révolutionnaire.
Il a cassé l'ouverture
record du week-end de beaucoup.
Il a rapporté 100 millions de dollars
dans dix jours
Cela a montré à Hollywood que
il y avait tout un monde
de propriétés
ce n'était pas forcément
originaire d'un film
qui peut être fait
dans les films.
L'accent de l'industrie cinématographique
n'était pas principalement
sur les bandes dessinées, cependant,
et Batman a été vu
comme un renouveau
des deux une fois
série télévisée à succès
et d'un 40
héros de pulp fiction.
Au cours des prochaines années,
cela verrait
sorties sur grand écran
pour Dick Tracy,
Le Fusée
et autres icônes
des séries cinématographiques
ainsi que des adaptations
d'émissions de télévision classiques.
Les studios étaient
aussi maintenant conscient
du box-office
potentiel de super-héros,
et regarda Marvel
pour les personnages
ça pourrait se traduire
au grand écran.
Mais les trois films
qui a émergé
dans le sillage de Batman -
Le punisseur,
Capitaine Amérique
et Les Quatre Fantastiques-
étaient à très petit budget
déceptions
que la plupart des publics
n'a pas eu la chance de voir.
Bandes dessinées Marvel
sont assis juste là,
la BD la plus vendue
en Amérique à cette époque.
Et certainement il doit y avoir
films à faire.
Eh bien, il y avait,
il y aurait.
Mais les premiers qui sont sortis
n'étaient pas ceux qui
quelqu'un voulait voir
et ils n'étaient pas
ceux qui
les gens étaient
particulièrement fier.
Alors que Marvel
les personnages ont échoué
pour réussir
faire la transition
sur grand écran,
dans le monde de la bande dessinée
ils prospéraient encore,
et l'industrie elle-même était
traversant une période de boom.
Grâce à la croissance
maturité du support,
et à un changement important
dans la culture des jeunes,
les bandes dessinées se vendaient soudainement
en nombre record,
avec de nouveaux éditeurs
et nouveaux titres
constamment lancé.
Comme cette sous-culture
propulsé dans le courant dominant,
à l'été 1992
Le chevalier noir de Michael Keaton
est venu au premier plan une fois
à nouveau dans Batman Returns.
Et ayant démontré
sa valeur au box-office
avec l'original,
cette fois directeur
L'imaginaire de Tim Burton
s'est donné carte blanche
dans une prise beaucoup plus excentrique
sur le caractère DC.
Batman piquant
contre la méchanceté jumelle
du Pingouin de Danny DeVito
et de Michelle Pfeiffer
Catwoman,
ça s'est avéré
une version beaucoup plus conflictuelle.
Le retour de Batman
était un cas de
Fabrication de Tim Burton
un conte gothique
dans le monde de Batman.
Et quelque chose qui a
toujours soufflé mon esprit
même quand j'ai vu le
film et j'avais 12 ans
est-ce que je pense
à moi-même,
si ce film n'était pas basé
sur des personnages que nous connaissions tous
il serait salué comme
un des grands art et essai
claqué
films fantastiques de notre époque.
Mange ton coeur,
Terry Gilliam.
Quand je suis allé voir
ça, j'ai vraiment adoré.
L'esthétique a d'abord été
comme rien que j'avais vu auparavant.
Certainement rien
dans tout type de monde de la bande dessinée.
Cette nature gothique.
C'était grave et sombre,
mais ce n'était pas sombre.
C'était toujours amusant.
Et pour moi, en tant que jeune
adolescent à ce point
et n'avait jamais vraiment ressenti
en tant que femme que
super-héros ou bandes dessinées
étaient vraiment pour moi
parce qu'à l'époque où j'ai grandi
ce n'était pas quelque chose
que beaucoup de
les jeunes femmes l'ont fait.
Donc je n'avais pas
une super-héroïne à idolâtrer,
mais ce que j'avais
est-ce une femme incroyablement cool
qui tombe par la fenêtre
et se fait lécher par les chats
et se transforme en
ce incroyablement sexy, impertinent,
puissant, excitant
Anti Hero.
j'ai toujours été
un grand fan de Catwoman.
Toujours. Et pour la voir réellement,
pas seulement sur grand écran,
pas seulement en tant que personnage principal,
mais en fait même s'adressant
le sexisme,
qu'elle traite
dans le bureau,
quelque chose qui semble si...
Eh bien, nous n'avons pas
tout à fait réglé ça.
Mais la voir
là-haut c'était énorme
et elle était puissante.
Elle était sexy,
ce qui, soit dit en passant, est bien.
J'ai adoré ce déguisement.
Je pense que c'était incroyable pour
une femme devait y être cousue.
Et elle a absolument tenu
la sienne contre Batman.
Je pense que c'était
incroyable.
Miaou.
je pense Batman
Returns est un film décent
mais ça a commencé en quelque sorte
tendance dans les films de Batman.
où les méchants sont devenus
plus important que le héros.
Aussi deux méchants
pour le prix d'un.
Ce film pour moi
se sent moins concentré
comme un film de Batman
comme c'est un
exploration de
ces personnages très étranges
comme vu à travers
Les yeux de Tim Burton.
Et ceux-ci
personnages étranges
et le ton sinistre
du film
qu'ils aient habité
limité son attrait plus large.
J'étais sur les livres de Batman
à l'époque
Batman Returns est sorti.
Et nos ventes ont baissé,
parce que les parents
étaient tellement bouleversés par le film.
Ils s'attendaient à emmener les enfants
voir un film Batman
vous pourriez emmener les enfants voir.
Le matériel Pingouin
était si effrayant
et Catwoman aussi
était si dérangeant.
que les parents étaient scandalisés.
Malgré une bonne santé
billetterie d'ouverture,
le film a souffert
d'un contrecoup,
forcer la restauration rapide
McDonald's géant
tirer un profit
accord de merchandising.
Clairement jamais prévu
comme un film familial,
Le retour de Batman
s'est avéré trop mature
pour l'été
marché à succès.
Mais cela n'a pas dissuadé
petits studios
d'investir
dans des adaptations de bandes dessinées,
et la boum
dans cette industrie signifiait
qu'il y avait maintenant beaucoup plus
personnages au choix.
Des éditeurs indépendants comme
Calibre, Dark Horse et Image
avait créé une richesse
de nouveaux héros,
et tandis que Marvel
luttait
pour obtenir ses caractères
sur l'écran,
des films comme The Mask,
Fil de fer barbelé et The Crow
a présenté ces
créations plus modernes.
Los Angeles, 1995.
Il a fallu trois ans pour
Warner Brothers de se regrouper,
repenser et
réinventer Batman.
Sous le choc de l'indignation
chez Tim Burton's dark and
sortie précédente singulière,
cette fois ils visent carrément
au marché familial.
Encore une fois, le casting
est un ensemble impressionnant,
avec Val Kilmer remplaçant
Michel Keaton
dans le rôle principal,
L'Oscar Tommy Lee Jones
comme double face
et d'Hollywood
meilleur acteur comique,
Jim Carrey,
comme Le Riddler,
aux côtés de Nicole Kidman et
Chris O'Donnell dans le rôle de Robin.
Derrière la caméra, ex-costume
créateur Joël Schumacher
visait à apporter un autre
vision de la série.
Pourtant, le film qui en résulte,
Batman pour toujours,
bien que
un succès commercial,
prouverait
une impasse créative.
Une fois Tim
Burton recule,
ce qu'il te reste c'est
bâtissons-nous sur
ce que Tim a fait
ou allons-nous dans une nouvelle direction?
Il y a toujours l'influence
et le pouvoir de la mémoire
de Batman
émission de télévision.
Ce sont donc les trois
directions principales que vous pouvez suivre
avec la franchise.
Ce que personne n'a considéré
était en train de faire
qu'est-ce que les bandes dessinées
faisaient,
parce que l'attitude d'Hollywood
vers les bandes dessinées était,
OK, qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
avec ce truc ?
Comment pouvons-nous le réparer
et en faire un film ?
Chaque fois qu'ils décrochent
une bande-dessinée
leur première pensée est
de quoi allons-nous nous débarrasser ?
Avec tous ces
différentes forces au travail
ce qui s'est passé ensuite était
Batman pour toujours.
C'était bruyant,
c'était impétueux.
Les impératifs
étaient commerciaux
et il y avait
beaucoup de doublures.
Tu m'as appelé ici pour ça ?
Le signal Bat n'est pas un bipeur.
Alors que j'aimerais pouvoir dire
mon intérêt pour toi était...
... purement professionnel.
Essayez-vous d'obtenir
sous ma cape, docteur ?
Une fille ne peut pas vivre
par la seule psychose.
C'est la voiture, non ?
Les filles adorent la voiture.
Par le temps
il est arrivé à Batman Forever,
nous étions toujours prêts à partir
voir un film de Batman.
C'est alors que les films de Batman
commencé à glisser des rails.
Encore une fois, nous avons eu deux méchants.
Nous avions un autre acteur
dans le costume de chauve-souris
qui n'étaient pas
peu disposé à accepter.
Val Kilmer semblait
somnambule à travers le rôle.
Mais il a été éclipsé
par les méchants.
Le très Joker de Tommy Lee Jones
comme tourner en tant que Two-Face.
Commençons cette fête
d'un coup.
C'était un personnage
qui n'est pas comme le Joker.
Et Jim Carrey étant Jim Carrey.
J'espère que vous avez fait plus.
Qui diable êtes-vous?
Juste un ami.
Mais tu peux m'appeler...
...Le Riddler.
Il semble Schumacher
voulu imposer
sa propre vision stylistique,
ce que je pense est
très influencé
par la version des années 1960.
Encore une fois, nous sommes retournés
aux angles de caméra biaisés.
Nous avons une approche néon,
plutôt que les couleurs day-glo
de la série télévisée Batman.
Mamelons de chauve-souris.
Dois-je aller plus loin ?
Bien que plus adapté
comme divertissement familial,
avec McDonald's
solidement de retour à bord
pour le merchandising
rattachement,
c'était Batman de retour
le territoire de la parodie du camp
et fans de BD
et les critiques
exprimé leur
déception.
Quand, en 1998,
Schumacher est revenu
avec un autre Batman,
George Clooney
pour le suivi,
les espoirs du studio étaient grands
pour un autre grand succès.
Pourtant, ce étoilé
spectacle
deviendrait tristement célèbre,
régulièrement voté comme l'un des
les pires films jamais réalisés.
je ne veux pas être méchant
mais je me sens comme Schumacher
détruit à lui tout seul
le film Batman
la franchise.
A sa décharge, je ne me sens pas
comme si c'était entièrement de sa faute.
J'ai l'impression d'être chez Warner Brothers
manque de compréhension
de l'histoire et des personnages
c'est pourquoi il s'est enfui
avec cette interprétation.
Mais oui, c'est pas bon.
Salut Freeze. Je suis Batman.
Tu ne m'envoies pas
à la glacière.
Batman et
Robin était le glas
ça ferait
les gens réalisent
vous ne pourriez pas les traiter
des films comme un magasin de t-shirts
et s'attendre à ce que les gens
venir chaque été.
J'ai entendu Kevin Feige chez Marvel
se référer à Batman et Robin
comme le plus important
mouvement de bande dessinée jamais fait
parce que c'était
si terriblement mauvais
qu'il signalait que
tout était mieux que ça.
Alors quelqu'un est venu
avec l'idée désespérée
de prêter réellement attention
au matériel source
parce que maintenant il y avait
rien d'autre à essayer de toute façon
alors autant essayer
faire comme ils l'ont fait.
Ce serait des années
avant cette nouvelle approche
s'est concrétisé.
En attendant,
tout comme la franchise Batman
écrasé et brûlé,
une baisse des ventes de bandes dessinées
vu toute l'industrie
passer d'un boom à l'autre
Presque toute la nuit.
Fin 1996,
leader de l'industrie Marvel
déposé son bilan.
Avec les bandes dessinées
eux-mêmes
ne plus en mesure
pour le maintenir à flot,
son seul espoir était
dans les films
qui étaient actuellement
en développement
avec les studios de cinéma
à l'époque,
et avec leur absence précédente
du succès au box-office,
leurs chances
parait mince.
Et puis, en 1998,
un film est sorti
concentré sur un personnage de Marvel
peu étaient même au courant...
...Lame.
La lame était
Le premier succès de Marvel
entrée en salle cinématographique dans
le monde des super-héros de bande dessinée.
Mais pour 99% des gens
aller à ce film
c'était "Oh, c'est un Wesley
Film d'action-horreur Snipes
où il joue un vampire
et il tue des vampires." Sympa!
C'est comme un mauvais rêve.
Il y a pire
sortir ce soir que les vampires.
Comme quoi?
Comme moi.
Il était surprenant que
Le premier succès cinématographique de Marvel
s'est avéré être Blade,
parce que même à l'intérieur
lecteurs de bandes dessinées
La lame était
un personnage obscur.
Il est apparu
dans la bande dessinée Marvel
"Tombe de Dracula
dans les années 1970.
Blade était un personnage
qui était à moitié vampire
qui chassait les vampires.
Pouvoir décrire
le personnage
en deux ou trois phrases
c'est tres important.
Si tu peux faire ça alors
le public peut accepter cela.
Je pense que le succès de
La lame était que
nous avons eu
une star d'action établie
ou quelqu'un qui était sur
la montée en tant que star d'action
Wesley Snipes.
Et nous avions
un film de vampire très amusant.
C'était probablement un
des premiers films à capitaliser
sur ce qui deviendra plus tard
l'air du temps des vampires,
moins la romance et les étincelles
de la série crépuscule.
Vous êtes l'un d'entre eux, n'est-ce pas.
Non, je suis autre chose.
Il y a un intéressant
leçon de Blade.
Le fait que le personnage
était donc relativement méconnu.
Il n'y a personne
cela pourrait dire,
"Hm, je pense que ça devrait
être plus comme ça."
Si vous mettez Superman
ou Batman à l'écran
c'est presque comme
un test de Rorschach.
Vous pouvez demander
n'importe quel directeur de film
ce qu'ils pensent d'un Superman
le film devrait avoir
et ils auront une réponse.
Ce n'est pas nécessairement
une bonne chose.
Demandez-leur ce qu'est un film Blade
devrait être comme, ils ne savent pas.
Cela pourrait être une bonne chose.
Lame fournie
une lueur d'espoir
pendant Marvel
heure la plus sombre,
pas seulement un succès
dans son droit
mais un seul d'un certain nombre
de projets en cours de développement
par différents studios.
Cette dernière minute
réapparition
n'aurait pas pu être
mieux chronométré.
Au cours de la décennie précédente
technologie digitale
avait avancé
à un rythme étonnant,
et cette évolution
s'était nourri directement
dans le monde cinématographique.
De Terminator 2
et Jurassic Park
au Titanic
et Starship Troopers,
dans l'ordinateur des années 1990
images générées, ou CGI,
a commencé à permettre
cinéastes
représenter de façon réaliste
l'infilmable auparavant.
À l'aube
du nouveau millénaire,
un film pionnier a vu le jour
qui a été inspiré
par la forme BD,
et cela a donné une vraie indication
de l'avenir du cinéma.
Quel était le
premier grand film de bande dessinée
qui a signalé
ce que les films pourraient faire?
Pour moi, c'est Matrix.
La matrice n'est pas
une adaptation en bande dessinée.
Je m'en fiche.
Les Wachowski venaient de
les univers de Jack Kirby
et Neal Adams
et tous les autres grands
les gens de la bande dessinée.
Ils étaient au courant.
Ils ont compris
la physique de celui-ci.
le facteur wow de celui-ci.
Ils l'ont d'abord mis à l'écran.
Cette dernière scène
dans le premier film quand Neo
se lance
dans le ciel...
Tout le monde au théâtre
qui possédait une boîte
plein de BD à la maison
eu la même pensée.
C'est Superman.
C'est à ça que ça devrait ressembler.
C'est ce que
nous avons voulu voir.
Comment se fait-il que je n'ai jamais vu ça
dans un film de super-héros ?
Pourtant maintenant
l'attente était terminée.
Après des années de sous-norme,
films à petit budget
ne pas apporter
l'univers Marvel à la vie,
En 2000
un de ses titres phares
fait sa transition
sur grand écran -
Les X-Men.
Développé par Stan Lee
et Jack Kirby,
ça deviendrait
la bande dessinée la plus vendue
des années 1990,
bien qu'au départ
ça a eu moins de succès...
Les X-Men ont une longue
et histoire alambiquée.
Ils ont commencé
comme l'une des dernières équipes
que Lee et Kirby ont créé
dans les années 1960.
Leur livre a été annulé
tous les cinq jours
il semblait que
à travers les années 60 et 70.
Et puis entre les mains de Chris
Claremont et Dave Cockrum
ils avaient
cette incroyable recrudescence.
L'appel
du titre était simple.
Une belle bande de personnages
qui venait d'être créé
Donc c'était ça
territoire totalement vierge,
et la possibilité de travailler
avec l'un des meilleurs artistes
dans l'entreprise, Dave Cockrum.
Spidey avait été autour
pour cinq ans.
La FF l'avait été.
Tous les autres
avait une continuité.
Tous les autres avaient
une poignée d'écrivains
qui était venu avant
qui a défini les personnages
dans la serie.
C'était un territoire vierge
et c'était irrésistible.
Les X-Men étaient
très différent
de Lee et Kirby
autres créations.
Où leurs anciens héros
étaient des gens normaux
transformé par l'exposition
aux rayons cosmiques
et les araignées radioactives,
c'était une équipe
des mutants
qui sont nés
avec leurs super pouvoirs
et rejeté par la société.
Pendant Claremont
17 ans de mandat sur le titre,
leur lutte a prouvé
particulièrement résonnant
pour une croissance sans cesse
nombre de lecteurs.
Les X-Men sont comme
les fans de BD
eux-mêmes.
Ils sont unis
communauté de parias.
Au sein de Marvel, il y avait
l'homme-araignée,
Les fans de Hulk, Daredevil
et puis il y avait
les fans des X Men
qui aurait aimé
l'univers à eux-mêmes.
j'ai connu des gens
qui lirait les X-Men
et ne lirait pas
autres bandes dessinées.
Ils étaient totalement immergés
dans les X-Men.
C'était comme les fans de punk rock.
Nous n'écoutons que du punk.
Nous n'allons pas
pour écouter autre chose.
Les X-Men avaient ce genre
d'effet sur les bandes dessinées.
Un film X-Men
avait été en développement
depuis le début des années 90,
quand Terminateur
réalisateur James Cameron
était lié à
le projet,
et bien que
Renard du 20e siècle
avait obtenu les droits
en 1994,
ils n'ont pas pu voir
la vraie valeur
de leur acquisition.
Fox ne pouvait pas
maîtriser le concept.
Alors j'ai fini par écrire
Un mémo
pour leur expliquer
qui sont les X-Men,
ce qui le rend différent.
Ce que j'ai dit, c'est que ce n'est pas
une histoire de super-héros.
Il s'agit d'essayer de faire
une place pour soi
dans un monde qui
franchement ne te veut pas.
Et tu dois
leur prouver
nous avons de la valeur,
nous avons le droit d'être ici.
Avec Les X-Men,
c'est devenu surtout une histoire
sur les immigrés
venant en Amérique
et essayer de s'intégrer.
J'ai ici une liste de noms
de mutants identifiés
vivre ici
aux Etats-Unis.
- Le sénateur Kelly.
- Maintenant, voici une fille dans l'Illinois,
qui peut traverser les murs.
Maintenant, qu'est-ce qui l'arrête
d'entrer dans un coffre de banque?
ou à la Maison Blanche
ou dans leurs maisons?
- Sénateur Kelly !
- Il y a même des rumeurs,
Mme Grey,
de mutants si puissants
qu'ils peuvent entrer dans nos esprits
et contrôler nos pensées,
enlever
notre libre arbitre donné par Dieu.
Je pense que le peuple américain
méritent le droit de décider
s'ils veulent leurs enfants
être à l'école avec des mutants,
être enseigné par des mutants.
C'est
un plus facilement embrassable
ou concept relatable
et malheureusement
plus réel que,
c'est les aventures
d'un milliardaire
qui veut lutter contre le crime.
Avec acclamé
le jeune réalisateur Bryan Singer
appelant les coups,
anticipation
pour le film a tourné haut,
pourtant comme avec Batman
une décennie à l'avance,
les fans étaient anxieux
concernant le casting
de leur personnage préféré,
le violent
anti-héros Wolverine.
Initialement Dougray Scott
a été jeté dans le rôle,
mais a été forcé
de revenir en arrière,
et Singer est revenu
à son choix initial,
Russel Crowe.
Crowe aussi n'était pas disponible,
mais il a suggéré à son ami
et son compatriote australien,
Hugh Jackman, pour le rôle,
un acteur surtout connu pour
son travail dans le théâtre musical.
Et comme Michael Keaton, il
avéré un choix inspiré.
Je pense que le succès
des films X-Men
Dépendait
le casting parfait
de Wolverine.
Il n'y a pas de personnage
probablement plus aimé
dans l'univers Marvel,
un personnage dont les origines
étaient entourés de mystère
le plus longtemps.
Ce film a vécu et est mort
sur Hugh Jackman
jouer à Wolverine
d'une manière que les fans
pourrait prendre du retard.
Allez, mon pote.
Cela ne marchera pas.
- Je sais ce que tu es.
- Vous avez perdu votre argent.
Tu continues comme ça,
vous perdez autre chose.
Chercher!
Carcajou
ne ferait pas partie
du paysage de la culture pop
sans Jackman.
Les deux sont intrinsèquement
liés les uns aux autres.
Aucun de ces films
travaillerait sans lui.
Il est si naturellement charismatique
et il est beau
sans être jolie
et il est viril
sans être brutal
et il vend
la sauvagerie de celui-ci.
Ils ont construit
toute cette franchise
et tout cet ensemble
autour de lui.
C'était cet Australien inconnu
qui est venu de nulle part
remplacer quelqu'un
et il a tout fait.
Comme Richard
Superman de Donner,
réalisateur Singer assemblé
une distribution d'ensemble,
y compris britannique
poids lourds
Patrick Stuart
et Ian McKellen
et étoile montante
Halle Berry.
Et en gardant
avec la BD,
le film a apporté un réalisme,
poids dramatique
à son fantastique
prémisse.
L'ambition des X-Men
s'est déclaré immédiatement.
Le film s'ouvre dans
un camp de concentration nazi
avec une famille marchant
à leur mort.
Ce n'était pas Ned Beatty
faire des blagues à Metropolis
Ce n'était pas Jack Nicholson
agression pour la caméra.
Cela disait,
"Allaient
dans le monde réel.
Nous apportons
le monde réel là-dedans."
Le film
ouvert avec 55 millions de dollars
ouverture le week-end.
C'était le cinquième plus grand
ouverture de tous les temps
et c'était la plus grande ouverture
week-end jamais pour une non-suite.
Parce que Bryan Singer n'avait pas
un gazillion de dollars
il devait mettre l'accent
sur le drame
et les personnages
et la narration.
C'est pourquoi ce film tient toujours
up, pas comme un film d'action,
parce qu'il y a
très peu d'action dedans,
mais ça marche toujours
comme un drame de caractère.
C'est un
film beaucoup plus adulte
que ses prédécesseurs,
De plusieurs façons
en partie parce qu'il aborde
grands enjeux politiques.
Je pense que c'est délibérément
se positionne
pas un film juste pour les enfants,
pas un film juste pour les fans.
Quelque chose qui est
une histoire d'origine,
donc tu n'as pas
avoir lu les bandes dessinées.
Mais si vous avez lu les bandes dessinées
alors vous obtenez toute la joie
et le plaisir de voir
tous ces gens ont réalisé.
Particulièrement post-Matrix,
le choix des déguisements
était très intéressant.
Alors ils ne vont pas avec
le costume jaune Wolverine.
Tout le monde porte du cuir,
tout le monde a l'air cool.
Et encore une fois, c'était un film cool.
Il y avait
beaucoup de femmes dedans.
QuandX-Men
est sorti comme un film
et tu avais ce genre
du casting 50-50,
non seulement tu étais
amener les gars
qui allaient
à voir quand même.
Tu avais beaucoup de femmes
qui voulait aller le voir aussi
parce que, hé, je veux y aller
voir kick ass poussins.
C'était tellement
un énorme frisson de voir ça.
Je sais pour beaucoup de gens
voir Batman sur
le grand écran était un gros problème.
Mais pour moi, c'était X-Men.
C'était voir
toutes ces femmes qui se battent.
J'ai adoré ça.
Après sa première
pas chancelants,
dans le sillage des X-Men
le blockbuster de super-héros
était opérationnel.
Les bandes dessinées étaient soudainement
une source populaire
pour un tout
gamme de films,
et dans le nouveau millénaire
œuvres acclamées
comme Ghost World
et l'oscarisé
Route de la perdition
a pris des bandes dessinées non fantastiques
et les a tournés
dans le cinéma sérieux.
Début 2002,
le film secondBlade s'est ouvert
et est devenu
une autre publicité
et succès critique,
pourtant tous les yeux étaient concentrés
sur la grande sortie de l'été.
Après une courte durée
Séries TV
et plusieurs
dessins animés à succès,
Le plus de Marvel
personnage bien connu
faisait son chemin
au grand écran...
L'incroyable homme-araignée était
un des plus
créations étonnantes
dans l'histoire de la bande dessinée.
Stan Lee et Steve Ditko
assembler toutes les grandes pièces
de super-héros.
Ils ont pris un enfant comme Robin.
Ils ont pris une tragédie familiale
comme Batman.
Et ils ont pris un alter ego
comme Superman.
Et ils ont tout mis ensemble.
Et c'est juste
absolument pris feu
parce que Spider-Man était le
premier héros de bande dessinée
avec toute gravité
qui représentait les lecteurs.
Regarder là-haut!
Sauvez mon bébé, s'il vous plaît !
Je suis assis là le soir de l'ouverture,
et je pense,
cela semble irréel, après tout
ces années à lire à ce sujet.
Genre, je regarde en fait
un film Spider-Man !
Voyant
Spider-Man se balançant
à travers l'écran
pour la première fois
eu autant d'impact
sur le public
en voyant Christopher Reeve
voler comme Superman
pour la première fois.
C'était un moment si important
pour les fans de BD.
Et ces fans étaient
sûr de savoir que,
pour la première fois,
une adaptation cinématographique
était entre les mains créatives
de l'un des leurs -
réalisateur Sam Raimi.
j'ai un
longue histoire avec Sam Raimi.
Je pense qu'il est le parfait
réalisateur pour Spider-Man.
La chose principale avec Sam est
il adore faire des films.
Et il aime Spider-Man.
C'est un grand geek de Spider-Man.
C'est un grand fan de BD.
Spider-Man, je sais qu'il adore ça.
Il est venu à ce projet
avec un esprit qui
n'avait pas été vu auparavant
par un cinéaste
adapter une bande dessinée.
Autant que Richard Donner
réussi avec Superman,
il n'a pas grandi
immergé dans Superman
la façon dont Sam Raimi a grandi
plongé dans les histoires
de Stan Lee
et Steve Ditko et John Romita.
C'est un gars qui savait
ce qui comptait dans Spider-Man
quand il a fait ses choix
pour le film.
ils n'ont pas été traités
à travers un filtre hollywoodien.
Et dans le
rôle de ce héros,
Sam Raimi a refusé
le choix du studio,
Freddie Prinz Jr.
en faveur de Tobey Maguire,
un acteur
qui avait été acclamé par la critique
dans les drames Pleasantville,
La tempête de verglas
et Wonder Boys.
Marvel avait beaucoup roulé
sur ce premier
Film Spiderman.
Il était donc extrêmement important
qui a été choisi comme Spider-Man,
Peter Parker, et qui était
choisi comme directeur.
je pense que le choix
de Tobey Maguire était parfait.
Pierre!
Que se passe-t-il là-dedans ?
Je fais de l'exercice.
Je ne suis pas habillé, tante May.
Eh bien, vous agissez
si étrangement, Peter.
D'accord merci.
Il était Peter Parker.
Il avait la voix
et le regard.
C'est ce que j'ai toujours imaginé
Peter Parker sera.
C'est parfait.
Le tout premier film
gagner plus de 100 millions de dollars
lors de son week-end d'ouverture,
Homme araignée
était une preuve supplémentaire que,
si c'est bien fait, super-héros
étaient d'or au box-office.
Et pour
l'industrie de la bande dessinée,
ces blockbusters étaient maintenant
apportant leurs personnages
à un énorme
public mondial.
La télévision a
exposé les gens aux personnages
ils n'avaient aucune idée
de quoi ils parlaient.
Peut-être qu'ils savaient qui ils étaient,
mais jusqu'à ce qu'ils voient le film
ils ne les comprennent pas.
je me souviens avoir vu
le premier film de Spider-Man
le premier Sam Raimi
Film Spiderman.
Et quand oncle Ben meurt
le public est tout déchiré.
- Reste en arrière, reste en arrière !
- C'est mon oncle !
- Ce qui s'est passé?
- Cric de voiture. Il a été abattu.
Nous venons d'appeler les ambulanciers.
Ils sont en route.
Reste en arrière!
Oncle Ben.
J'ai connu cette histoire
depuis que j'ai dix ans.
ça m'a visiblement touché
quand je l'ai lu.
Mais je n'y ai jamais pensé
sur un public plus large.
Quand oncle Ben meurt,
le public est dévasté.
Waouh!
Voici où les choses changent.
Quand tu restes avec le noyau
d'une création comique
que j'aimais
et des millions d'autres aimés,
traduire ça pour filmer correctement
vous allez gagner de l'argent.
Conscient de
les bénéfices potentiels,
la machine hollywoodienne
maintenant passé en surmultipliée.
À l'été 2003,
Hulk a été libéré,
et avec Le Fantastique
Film à quatre et Daredevil
déjà en fabrication,
seulement six ans
après avoir fait face à la faillite,
Les créations de Stan Lee étaient maintenant
les propriétés les plus demandées
dans le divertissement
entreprise.
Les cinéastes ont soudainement réalisé
il y a un marché
pour le cinéma
qui sont plus grands que la vie
avec des héros colorés
avec de merveilleux effets spéciaux
et évidemment où pouvez-vous
obtenir mieux que ça
que dans les bandes dessinées,
surtout dans Marvel Comics.
Hulk était
la deuxième
Création de bandes dessinées Marvel
entre Stan Lee
et Jack Kirby dans les années 60.
Encore une fois, en termes d'archétypes,
qui est-il?
C'est Frankenstein,
avec Jekyll et Hyde
sorte de mélange.
Le médecin maigre qui obtient
bombardé de rayons gamma
et se transforme en
cette grosse brute
et il n'a aucun intérêt
dans la défense des libertés civiles
ou les vertus civiles ou l'Amérique
de quelque manière que.
Il est complètement hors de lui-même.
L'incroyable Hulk
était le premier de Marvel
grand succès télévisuel
à la fin des années 70 et au début des années 80.
C'était bien joué et il a fallu
le même genre de thème
comme Le Fugitif,
l'émission de télévision des années 60,
et il y avait
un thème tragique à ce sujet
ce que je pense était vrai
à la bande dessinée.
Il était d'un genre différent
de super-héros -
quelqu'un qui ne voulait pas
les pouvoirs qu'il avait.
Et l'émission de télévision,
même si les fans de BD
avait beaucoup à
chicaner avec,
je trouve que c'est très réussi
pour son milieu pour son temps.
Mais traduire Hulk
dans le grand écran
bien sûr tu voulais
plus que ça.
Maintenant, vous pourriez avoir un plus grand
Hulk, un Hulk beaucoup plus fort,
plus fidèle aux bandes dessinées.
Mais être vrai
aux bandes dessinées
n'était pas le primaire
intention
pour l'équipe créative
derrière Hulk de 2003.
Primé
Le cinéaste taïwanais Ang Lee
était le plus
acclamé par la critique
et à l'international
célèbre réalisateur
jamais assumer
une adaptation de super-héros.
Son film était plus intéressé
en psychologie qu'en action,
son script imprégné
dans les allusions
aux classiques littéraires
et la mythologie.
J'ai adoré Hulkin 2003.
Je l'ai aimé.
Si je n'avais pas voulu
aller voir le film
parce que j'ai regardé l'émission de télévision,
ce que j'ai fait,
donc j'aimais déjà Hulk,
Je serais parti
à cause du réalisateur.
À ce moment,
c'était assez évident
ce film de bande dessinée
allaient continuer.
Et donc je pense que c'était
un choix vraiment intéressant
prendre un réalisateur
comme Ang Lee et dire,
"Voilà un grand gars vert
qui porte un pantalon violet.
Faites ce que vous voulez avec lui."
Le gamma est trop élevé.
Bruce, je ne peux pas l'arrêter.
Harper, sors !
Sortir!
L'idée de
quelqu'un comme Tim Burton
faire un film de bande dessinée
avait du sens pour les gens.
Ang Lee. Tu es comme,
attendez, et maintenant?
Mais je pense que
en quelque sorte donné
un peu plus de pied
aux films de bande dessinée
pour les personnes susceptibles d'avoir
les a rejetés comme des trucs pour enfants.
Hulk est
très bien une image d'Ang Lee.
Mais c'est aussi super duper
bande dessinée visuellement
en termes d'utilisation de panneaux
en tant que dispositifs d'édition,
le vraiment brillant
couleurs primaires,
le sans vergogne
une action plus grande que nature.
Non!
Mais ce fut un flop.
je pense que c'était
un autre cas d'audience
ne pas embrasser
un drame très art et essai
qui était déguisé
comme un film de bande dessinée.
Et je pense encore,
comme avec Batman Returns,
la leçon que Hollywood
pris de qui est comme
faire venir de grands réalisateurs
mais ne les laissez pas
devenir complètement fou.
Son ambition
était louable
par rapport à l'éruption
des films qui ont suivi.
Avec Ben Affleck
véhicule Daredevil,
le deuxième grand écran
sortie de The Punisher
et un tiède,
Les Quatre Fantastiques familiaux,
la série de succès basés sur Marvel
s'est terminé,
tandis que la Catwoman
long métrage solo
avec Halle Berry
a rapidement fait son chemin
dans le pire-film-
listes de tous les temps.
Pourtant les séquelles ont gardé
le drapeau du super-héros qui flotte,
avec Spider-Man de Sam Raimi
2 et le X2 de Bryan Singer
salué comme parmi
le meilleur du genre.
Spiderman 2
est largement considéré
l'un des
plus grandes suites,
en particulier
dans les films de super-héros.
Les effets spéciaux avaient évolué
ce peu plus encore.
Même en seulement
ces quelques années
entre les films
ils se développent,
ils obtiennent
ce peu plus de poids pour eux.
Et ils ne font que pousser
ce qu'ils peuvent en faire.
Particulièrement avec
le personnage du Dr Octopus
et tout ce genre
de membres extensibles.
Il a certains des
coups de pied arrêtés toujours remarquables
en termes de cinéma supérieur,
de ce combat dans le train
et quand ils se battent
sur le côté du bâtiment.
Il obtient juste ce truc
si juste.
C'est juste extrêmement divertissant.
En termes de
être fidèle à la source,
X2 était probablement le plus haut
filigrane à cette époque
pour fondamentalement
une bande dessinée prend vie.
X2 ressemble à un commerce
livre de poche en une seule séance.
Les 50 premières minutes de X2,
le premier acte, je pense encore
est l'un des meilleurs
cinéma de bande dessinée jamais réalisé.
Ne tirez pas!
Il obtient
encore plus politique dans X2
et il devient plus sombre.
Somnambule
était un personnage fantastique
et ses premières séquences
à la Maison Blanche,
met absolument en valeur CGI -
étaient très drôles, très cool.
Et en fait vraiment pas comme
choses que nous avions vues auparavant.
X2 était
celui qui montrait
ils peuvent vraiment
faire tout.
ils utilisaient juste
leurs pouvoirs tout le temps
sans le donner
une seconde pensée.
Et non seulement les
effets spéciaux géniaux,
ils se sentent sans couture.
Ils se sentent comme...
... ils ne sont pas tendus
dans un sens narratif.
Et c'est pourquoi je pense
ils vont "wow".
Ça y est. Nous l'avons fait.
Et comme
progrès de la technologie
aidé à transporter des super-héros
sur grand écran,
ils ont également contribué à apporter
les passionnés de BD
Plus proche les uns des autres.
Où le seul forum
pour les lecteurs
avait été auparavant
pages de lettres
et la bande dessinée
se stocker,
avec la venue
de l'ère numérique,
fans autrefois isolés
a adopté Internet
et tendu la main aux autres
qui partageaient leur passion.
Bien sûr,
Internet a tellement fait
propulser et exploser
culture des fans
pour les bandes dessinées et toutes sortes
de l'obsession des fans.
Si tu étais fan
de ces bandes dessinées,
tu te sentais un peu seul.
vous savez sont là
d'autres personnes là-bas
autre qu'une poignée
d'amis qui sont dans ce domaine.
Ce qu'a fait Internet
avec les babillards électroniques,
maintenant il crée ce large
communauté internationale
où vous pouvez commenter
chaque bande dessinée ou super-héros.
Vous pouvez réellement aider
façonner les bandes dessinées
parce que les écrivains,
les artistes,
entendrait parler
cela aussi.
La culture des babillards électroniques
de la fin des années 90 et du début des années 2000,
tu as réussi à combler un fossé
entre les fans
et les créatifs
et l'artiste et le
les écrivains étaient plus accessibles.
Vous pourriez avoir des conversations
et dialoguer avec eux
et les fans étaient
capable de se connecter
et parler de ce qu'ils ont aimé
ou ce qu'ils n'aimaient pas
à propos de films ou de bandes dessinées
ou quoi que ce soit.
Alors nous avons commencé à voir,
à cause d'Internet
et les communautés en ligne,
l'explosion
de la culture des fans
qui finalement
je pense a conduit
qu'il y ait
autant de convention
et conventions de fans
comme il y en a aujourd'hui.
La culture de la bande dessinée a
devenir plus fan culture.
Juste des gens qui se réunissent
et célébrer ce qu'ils aiment.
Les premières années
du nouveau millénaire
étaient remarquables pour
l'explosion
de la bien-aimée Marvel
personnages
sur grand écran
pour la première fois.
2005, cependant,
était l'année
dans lequel le chevalier noir
encore une fois revenu.
Vous cherchez à essuyer
l'ardoise propre
après l'extravagance
et incohérence
des années Joel Schumacher,
Warner Brothers s'est tourné vers
jeune, célébré
réalisateur britannique
Christophe Nolan
pour recommencer la série,
avec Batman Begins.
Et en racontant
cette histoire,
l'équipe créative de Nolan
et David S. Goyer,
l'écrivain derrière
la franchise Blade,
regardé directement
aux bandes dessinées -
notamment celle de Frank Miller
histoire d'origine séminale
Batman: première année
et la production pionnière de
Denny O'Neil et Neal Adams
dans les années 1970.
Christopher Nolan a fait
quelque chose plutôt
remarquable et simple.
Il a été le premier grand cinéaste
raconter l'histoire de,
comme on disait en 1940,
qui est Batman
et comment il est devenu.
C'est le premier film d'origine
de Batman.
L'origine de Batman
est juste énorme.
C'est tellement émouvant
et tellement efficace
et si bien fait
par Chris Nolan
que presque cette seule décision
lui a donné les trois quarts
de son film.
Le travail qui
Denny et moi avions fait
influencé ce premier film,
et tu as pu le voir
directement sur l'écran.
Des films DC
qui avait été fait,
ce premier de ces trois,
juste tueur,
c'est un film tueur.
Le
réalisation de Batman Begins
ne peut pas être sous-estimé.
de Christophe Nolan
un brillant cinéaste.
Commencez par ça.
Et regarde le film se dérouler
la façon dont il raconte l'histoire.
L'utilisation d'effets pratiques
à huis clos
s'éloigner de CGI
dès que possible
pas parce que
c'est un problème financier
mais parce que
des problèmes esthétiques
et vous avez un niveau de la rue
version de Batman
que tout le monde dans le monde
sauf peut-être Joel Schumacher
était prêt pour.
Comme Superman
et X-Men avant lui,
Batman commence
présenté une abondance
de talent d'acteur
incarner les grands rôles.
Aux côtés d'acclamé mais
acteur britannique peu connu
Christian Bale
comme Bruce Wayne,
étaient Liam Neeson,
Michael Caine, Gary Oldman
et beaucoup d'autres
acteurs estimés
dans l'un des plus impressionnants
moulages d'ensemble jamais assemblés.
Cela a penché le film
poids dramatique considérable,
et dès sa sortie,
ça s'est mis tout de suite
une nouvelle référence
pour le cinéma de super-héros.
Batman Begins m'a époustouflé
quand il est sorti.
Je savais qui était Christian Bale
donc j'étais impatient de voir
ce qu'il en a fait.
Mais je n'en avais aucune idée.
Et je connaissais des trucs de Nolan
Mais je ne savais pas
ça allait être ça.
Il était si bon
et l'histoire était si sombre
et tellement ancré
en réalité.
C'était une toute nouvelle chose
pour les films de bandes dessinées.
Une tempête arrive.
L'écume devient nerveuse
parce que tu as tenu tête à Falcone.
C'est un début.
La Commission Loeb a mis en place un énorme
groupe de travail pour vous attraper.
Il pense que tu es dangereux.
Qu'en penses-tu?
Je pense que vous essayez d'aider.
Mais je me suis trompé avant.
Nolan n'était pas un grand fan de BD.
Et il ne venait pas de
le point de vue d'un fan
qui a eu sa chance
faire ce qu'il voulait.
Il le regardait comme
un cinéaste dramatique sérieux
qui a eu l'occasion
prendre cette chose
et le rendre réel.
Les Batman de Nolan
étaient la première fois
que quelqu'un s'est approché
mythologie des super-héros
en tant que légitime
récit dramatique.
Je donne à Warners et Nolan un
beaucoup de mérite pour s'être engagé
dans la mesure où ils l'ont fait
pour apporter ce réel
parce que je pense qu'il y a
toute une génération de gens
c'est leur version
de Batman.
C'était déterminant.
Batman commence
aidé à apporter
un nouveau niveau de respect
à la fois aux films de super-héros et
aux bandes dessinées elles-mêmes.
L'année de sa
sortie, 2005,
a aussi vu
adaptations de bandes dessinées
concourir pour la première fois
à Cannes,
le plus prestigieux
festival international du cinéma.
Sin City, réalisé
par Robert Rodríguez
et Une histoire de violence,
par un cinéaste canadien chevronné
David Cronenberg,
continué dans la tradition
des films précédents
Route de la perdition
et le monde fantôme
en démontrant que
les bandes dessinées étaient une forme d'art
être pris au sérieux.
Les choses qui sont sorties
ce n'était pas
basé sur les super-héros
vraiment montré beaucoup de gens
qui ne lit pas de BD
que c'était plus
que les gars en Spandex.
Je pense que ça a poussé les gens à prendre
le médium plus au sérieux.
Que ce n'était pas seulement
les histoires de pulpe.
Que c'était que tu pouvais dire
un très beau récit
et vous aviez une autre couche.
Vous aviez les visuels.
L'urgence de
des bandes dessinées vraiment de haute qualité
commence à traverser.
Route de la perdition,
en particulier,
Je pense que c'est fantastique
que les gens ne savent pas
c'est basé sur une bande dessinée.
J'aime leur dire et dire,
"Oh, c'est très
adaptation fidèle aussi."
Tu les vois
se gratter la tête.
Ce doute de leur sens
de ce qu'est une bande dessinée
est ce qui a conduit à tous les grands
choses qui se sont passées depuis.
Pourtant dans les années
immédiatement après
la sortie de Batman Begins,
le genre semblait encore chancelant.
Les adaptations Marvel se sont poursuivies
patauger,
avec Elektra,
Ghost Rider et une suite des Quatre Fantastiques
tout recevoir
un accueil mitigé,
tandis que des troisièmes films
en série éprouvée
X-Men et Spider-Man
fans déçus.
Derrière la
scènes, cependant,
Marvel cherchait à prendre
son sort entre ses mains.
Dans les années 90 Marvel
licenciait ses propriétés
à une variété
de différents studios.
Ainsi, par exemple,
Paramount avait Iron Man,
Thor, Capitaine América,
Je pense que ça aurait pu avoir
Panthère noire à l'époque.
Fox avait les X-Men
univers bien sûr.
Sony avait Spider-Man,
Universal avait The Hulk.
Mais au milieu des années 2000, mené par
un gars appelé David Maisel
Marvel a décidé
ils essaieraient d'employer
un modèle différent
de réalisation de films.
Maisel a suggéré
que Marvel développe
et produire
films en interne,
devenir une société de production
dans son droit
et maintenir la créativité
et contrôle financier
sur ses propres propriétés.
C'était un geste risqué,
puisqu'il obligeait l'entreprise à
obtenir un financement conséquent,
encore Marvel
poussé vers l'avant,
avec les droits
à seulement une poignée
de son plus
personnages marquants.
En 2007,
ils sont passés à la production,
et sous la tutelle
de David Maisel
et producteur Marvel
Kévin Feige,
ont bientôt annoncé leur
plans à venir à la presse.
j'avais publié une histoire
qui était sur la première page de
la section affaires du LA Times.
Il y avait une photo de Hulk
et Thor et Iron Man.
C'était avant
le premier film d'Iron Man.
Et le titre
était "L'équipe B".
Ce n'était pas X-Men,
la meilleure vente
bande dessinée en Amérique.
Ce n'était pas Spider-Man.
Ces personnages
n'étaient pas aussi connus.
Mais il n'y a rien de mal
d'être un inconnu
tant que tu fais
une bonne première impression.
C'est
d'Iron Man
et son alter
moi Tony Stark,
le héros qui ferait face
la première version
des studios Marvel en 2008.
Comme la lame
une décennie à l'avance,
encore une fois
c'était un personnage
Avec peu
la reconnaissance du public,
bien que comique
lecteurs de livres
avait suivi
ses aventures
depuis que Stan Lee l'a créé
retour en 1963.
Quand Marvel est entré dans
son deuxième niveau
personnages
les fans de BD, bien sûr,
savaient qui ils étaient
mais le public plus large ne l'a pas fait.
En avance sur Iron Man
film qui sort
il y avait
une grande campagne publicitaire
pour s'assurer que les gens
savait qu'il n'était pas un robot.
Bien sûr, les fans de bandes dessinées
le savait déjà.
Iron Man est intéressant
caractère et très opportun.
C'était un personnage né
comme les États-Unis
se préparait
partir en guerre au Vietnam.
C'était un personnage
qui est sorti
de l'armée
complexe industriel.
Tony Stark travaille
en tant qu'entrepreneur de la défense
avec le gouvernement,
blessé au Vietnam,
et construit ceci
Costume d'Iron Man
parce qu'il est si brillant
avec la technologie.
C'est facilement adaptable
à notre époque
où les États-Unis
est dans des guerres de type Vietnam,
en Afghanistan et en Irak
à l'époque.
Une fois de plus nous avons eu
cette tension entre
essayer de maîtriser
cette technologie
mais pourtant quelqu'un qui se sent
à part ça aussi.
Il en fait toujours partie
complexe militaro-industriel.
Mais il précise que
il va attirer l'attention
ailleurs et aider les gens.
J'ai vu de jeunes américains tués
par les armes mêmes que j'ai créées
pour les défendre et les protéger.
Et j'ai vu que je...
... faisait partie d'un système
c'est confortable
avec zéro responsabilité.
Que s'est-il passé là-bas ?
J'avais les yeux ouverts.
je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais plus
offrir à ce monde
que de simplement fabriquer des choses
faire sauter.
C'est pourquoi,
en vigueur immédiatement,
je ferme
la fabrication d'armes...
Pour une technologie
culture obsédée
vous ne pouvez vraiment pas obtenir
un meilleur super-héros qu'Iron Man
jouer à ces tensions,
cet amour-haine
ou relation amour-peur
que nous avons tous
avec la technologie.
Jarvis, es-tu là ?
A votre service monsieur.
Affichage de la tête de jauge.
Vérifier.
Toutes les préférences
depuis l'interface d'accueil.
Ça ira, monsieur.
je connais le fer
L'homme était en quelque sorte risqué
parce que les gens ne savaient pas
qui était ce personnage.
Mais j'étais vraiment excité
et la raison était...
... Je ressens ça avec quelque chose
comme Batman ou Captain America
il y avait ce sentiment que
vous n'allez pas le faire correctement.
Tu vas gâcher
mon Captain America, mon Batman.
Où Iron Man, parce que beaucoup de
les gens ne savaient pas qui il était,
vous pourriez entrer et à peu près
fais tout ce que tu veux.
C'était donc un geste brillant.
Si vous allez lancer
un univers cinématographique
c'est tout à fait unique,
tu dois le faire avec quelqu'un
que personne ne sait.
Mais le casting
quelqu'un que personne ne connaît
n'était pas une option.
Embarquement
un acteur familier
pour jouer Tony Stark
était crucial
au succès du film
Marvel a approché Robert
Downey Jr. pour le rôle.
Un acteur oscarisé
qui a émergé dans les années 1980
et dont la carrière
avait déraillé
par des problèmes de toxicomanie
et l'emprisonnement
la décennie suivante,
à l'époque d'Iron Man
sa carrière était
à nouveau en hausse,
et il a prouvé
le choix parfait.
C'est le
rôle d'une vie pour lui.
Beaucoup de gens pensaient
Chaplin l'était.
Je pense que ce gars est né
être Tony Stark.
Robert a grandi
aux yeux du public.
Tout bon et mauvais
c'est arrivé dans sa vie
tout le monde a vu.
Et Tony Stark est un gars qui
aussi grandi aux yeux du public.
C'est un génie. Tout le monde
apprécie son talent.
Il était logique d'avoir
Robert Downey
Jr. fais ça.
Il a une histoire
avec abus de substances
et Iron Man a une histoire
avec la toxicomanie.
Robert Downey Jr.
avait traversé des trucs.
Il était encore
un acteur respecté
mais sa carrière n'était pas
florissante comme elle l'est maintenant.
Donc je pense que ce qu'il a fait
pour Iron Man,
Iron Mandid pour lui.
Tony Stark
est un personnage brillant.
D'une certaine manière, il est en quelque sorte
de comparable à Batman
en ce sens qu'il
est multimillionnaire
et c'est un génie.
Mais cela faisait partie
de l'appel
parce que l'obscurité
dans Batmanest fantastique
et ça marche pour lui.
Mais ce qui a fonctionné pour Iron
L'homme est qu'il était vraiment drôle.
- Bonjour Tony. Souviens-toi de moi?
- Bien sûr que non.
Vous avez choisi Robert Downey Jr.
qui avait célèbre
avait ses propres problèmes
qui n'est pas un adolescent.
Il n'y avait aucun moyen
quelqu'un a pensé
ce film était
uniquement pour les enfants.
Il a abordé de grands thèmes.
Il y avait des scènes
situé en Afghanistan.
Il y avait Jeff Bridges dedans.
il y en a plusieurs
passe dans ce film.
Homme de fer
a été vendu avec succès
sous forme de bande dessinée
film de super-héros
aux gens qui autrement
peut être gêné
aller à une bande dessinée
film de super-héros.
Il y avait des stars de cinéma pour adultes.
Robert Downey Jr., Gwyneth
Paltrow, Jeff Bridges.
C'était presque un prestigieux
image de bande dessinée.
juste à côté
Batman commence.
Il sort
début mai,
choque tout le monde
en faisant 102 millions de dollars
le week-end d'ouverture.
Deuxième plus grande ouverture
pour une non-suite jamais
au-delà de Spider-Man.
Ce lundi
Marvel sort et dit,
« D'accord, voici quoi
nous faisons la prochaine."
Marvel a annoncé publiquement
un ambitieux
ardoise de fabrication
qui visait
sortir des films solo
pour tout de
ses personnages clés,
aboutissant à une équipe
film Les Vengeurs.
Et tandis que son autre version
de 2008, L'Incroyable Hulk,
s'est avéré moins efficace
qu'Iron Man,
le studio était confiant
ça pourrait amener des super-héros
à l'écran
comme jamais auparavant.
Comme Marvel l'a apprécié
le premier de nombreux succès,
Le favori de DC est revenu à
les salles de cinéma encore une fois.
Et où Batman Begins avait
créé une nouvelle référence
pour la bande dessinée
adaptations,
Le Chevalier Noir
était une suite bien plus sombre
qui a vu
Christophe Nolan
continuer à pousser
les limites
du cinéma fantastique
et a apporté Batman
ennemi juré le Joker
retour sur grand écran.
Ce rôle
serait immortalisé
par l'acteur australien
Heath Ledger,
qui est mort quelques mois
avant la sortie du film.
L'obscurité
du Chevalier noir,
était assez surprenant.
Il est vraiment allé dans des endroits qui
peut-être vous attendriez-vous
un thriller policier auquel aller
plus qu'un film de bande dessinée.
Mais je pense que cela avait été
tête de série dans Batman Begins
prendre beaucoup plus
approche réaliste et sérieuse
au personnage,
le mettre dans un Gotham
qui se sentait beaucoup plus
comme une ville en proie au crime
qu'une bande dessinée
métropole du livre.
Les gens étaient vraiment excités
pour voir une histoire de Batman-Joker
situé dans ce monde
avec le casting cool
de Heath Ledger
comme un assez effrayant
à la recherche de Joker.
Gardez à l'esprit l'aperçu
est sorti avant de mourir
donc nous avions déjà une bonne idée
de quel genre de Joker
il serait.
Vous voyez, c'est fou
Batman a créé Gotham.
Si vous voulez commander
à Gotham,
Batman doit enlever son masque
et se rend.
Oh, et chaque jour il ne le fait pas,
les gens vont mourir.
Il y avait
beaucoup d'intérêt pour ça
parce que c'était celui de Heath Ledger
dernier rôle complet au cinéma.
Allez allez.
Je veux que tu le fasses.
Allez.
Allez allez.
Je veux que tu le fasses.
Allez, frappe-moi.
Allez, frappe-moi !
Frappez-moi!
Tu ne vois tout simplement pas
beaucoup de spectacles comme ça,
notamment en termes de
méchants dans les films de super-héros
qui sont gentils
d'aussi intense.
Il a clairement creusé si profondément
dans ce personnage
et était vraiment
assez terrifiant.
Et c'est évidemment
une des choses principales
dont les gens se souviennent et aiment
à propos du Chevalier noir,
Les performances de Heath Ledger.
Si Stanley
Kubrick avait vécu assez longtemps
faire un film de super-héros
il aurait été
Le Chevalier Noir.
C'était la première fois
que quelqu'un a commis
aux ressources
tu aurais besoin
sortir des bandes dessinées
de la classe de la culture pop.
Ce n'était pas
un film de bande dessinée incroyable.
C'était un film incroyable
il s'est avéré qu'il s'agissait
un personnage de bande dessinée.
Et il y a une grande différence.
Les représentations
sont ravissantes.
Et le calibre du talent
il s'entourerait
faire ces films
est stupéfiant.
Avec un
réalisateur comme Nolan,
produire ces
des films incroyablement cinématographiques,
ce n'est pas si surprenant
que c'étaient vraiment
les premiers films de super-héros
qui ont été sérieusement envisagés
pour la gloire des récompenses.
Heath Ledger a reçu le
Oscar pour sa prestation
après sa mort.
Bien qu'aucun de ces films
ont été nominés pour le meilleur film,
il y a eu un petit tollé
qu'ils devraient être -
pourquoi ne devrions-nous pas les prendre,
non seulement au sérieux
dans leur propre monde,
mais pourquoi cela ne devrait-il pas être pris
sérieux comme un morceau de cinéma?
Et suite
le succès d'Iron Man
et Le Chevalier Noir,
adaptations de bandes dessinées
se propager comme un ouragan
à travers la culture populaire.
Les studios courent désespérément
trouver de nouveaux personnages
et titres
apporter à la
grand écran,
pendant qu'Iron Man revenait
pour une suite réussie
et Wolverine de Hugh Jackman
a été tiré de l'épave
de la série X-Men
jouer son propre rôle
aventures cinématographiques.
Ayant signé
une opération de rachat lucrative
avec Disney en 2011,
Marvel Studios revient avec
les deux prochaines tranches
de son canon cinématographique.
Le premier de ces
être libéré était Thor,
et comme Iron Man
cela représentait
les personnages
débuts sur grand écran.
Thor est un dieu du tonnerre
qui a cet énorme pouvoir
arme de destruction massive
que lui seul peut ramasser
parce qu'il est la seule personne
digne de lever ce fardeau.
je pense que
Bandes dessinées Marvel,
avec Stan Lee
et encore Jack Kirby,
ont pu puiser dans ce
autre royaume des dieux qui
nous n'étudions pas vraiment
dans la culture occidentale.
Nous avons nos Grecs
et nos romains
mais les dieux nordiques
sont très cool.
Un dieu du tonnerre qui
fait tonner avec un marteau
et peut tirer
éclairs.
C'est quelque chose
nous n'avions pas vu auparavant.
Malgré le personnage
longévité dans le monde de la bande dessinée,
il a de nouveau semblé
une perspective risquée
pour un public plus large.
Pourtant Marvel Studios,
et son cerveau,
Président de production
Kévin Feige,
étaient convaincus qu'ils
pourrait faire de Thor un succès.
Avec l'acteur britannique vétéran
et le cinéaste Kenneth Branagh
à bord
diriger le projet,
ils ont même modifié leur
formule éprouvée
et casting inconnu
acteur australien
Chris Hemsworth incarnera
ce héros tout aussi inconnu
Juste l'idée que
vous avez la mythologie nordique
avec la prose shakespearienne
dans ce fantastique,
fou Jack Kirby sur acid world.
Je me souviens quand
ils ont annoncé le film.
J'étais comme, "Comment diable
vont-ils...?"
Tout le reste
est tellement ancré dans la réalité
et Thor est cette seule chose
que je ne pouvais tout simplement pas voir
comment ça irait.
Quand je me suis assis pour la première fois
avec les gens de Marvel
ils ont dit: "C'est le plus
propriété difficile que nous avons.
Nous avons tellement de façons
échouer à le faire."
J'ai pensé, "Eh bien, c'est super,
bon départ."
Mais quand j'ai regardé ça
il a dit, quel est le genre?
Il a dit, action, science-fiction,
fantastique, aventure, drame.
Cela fait beaucoup de catégories,
n'est-ce pas?
J'ai dit, "Je pense qu'il a tout
ces choses dans les bandes dessinées.
Le plus grand défi est le ton."
Thor potentiellement sur papier
est tout à fait un
vente difficile.
Et ça s'étire certainement
les domaines de la crédibilité.
Pendant que vous avez configuré Iron Man
avec ce gars du monde réel
qui regarde
aux problèmes du monde réel
et est fixé
d'une manière très réelle
et c'est très grave,
c'est comme, et maintenant on y va
avoir un dieu nordique -
est assez difficile à vendre.
Ce qu'il a fait de manière experte
est-ce que c'était vraiment drôle.
- Cette boisson, je l'aime.
- Je sais, c'est super, non ?
Un autre!
Désolé. C'était un petit accident.
- Ca c'était quoi?
- C'était délicieux.
- J'en veux un autre.
- Vous auriez pu le dire.
- Je viens de faire.
- Non, je veux dire demander, gentiment.
- Je ne voulais pas manquer de respect.
- D'accord, plus de fracas.
Accord?
Vous avez ma parole.
Essentiellement,
c'est un fantasme brillant
poisson hors de l'eau comédie
et ne s'est pas pris
sérieusement du tout.
Chris Hemsworth
était le choix parfait.
Alors est-ce
à quoi ressembles-tu normalement?
Plus ou moins.
C'est un bon coup d'oeil.
Étant donné à quel point les rails
Thor aurait pu être,
Je pensais qu'ils avaient fait un excellent travail.
Et Hemsworth aussi.
Ce type n'est pas une blague en tant qu'acteur.
Comme, ouais, il est grand et attelé
et jolie et tout.
Ce mec est vraiment bon,
car c'est un rôle ingrat.
Cela aurait pu être
si ridicule et si stupide.
Bien que moins
réussi qu'Iron Man,
Thor a prouvé
un autre tirage au box-office,
et l'anticipation était maintenant
courir haut
pour l'autre de Marvel
grosse sortie de 2011,
Capitaine Amérique:
Le premier vengeur.
Et ce personnage
était le super-héros le plus âgé
dans l'entreprise
répertoire,
un symbole de propagande datant
retour au début des années 1940
et l'entrée de l'Amérique
dans la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Restant vrai
au concept de Stan Lee,
Capitaine Amérique:
Le premier vengeur
était une histoire d'origine
fixé principalement pendant
la seconde Guerre mondiale,
et introduit le public
au personnage
devant son
renaissance actuelle.
Avec un autre
relatif inconnu
jouer à Captain America,
Chris Evans,
et directeur d'action
Joe Johnston à la barre,
malgré plus large
reconnaissance publique
du personnage principal,
encore une fois le film
n'était pas un coup sûr.
A sa sortie
cela s'est avéré diviseur.
Quand j'ai entendu pour la première fois
ils allaient avoir
un film Captain America,
j'étais concerné
parce qu'il a dans le passé
été plutôt ringard.
Et il a été créé
comme un truc de propagande.
Alors j'ai l'impression, surtout avec
une tenue rouge, blanche et bleue,
c'est difficile à faire.
Je pense que le premier film
vraiment vendu ça.
C'était très clair
qu'il a été créé,
que ce costume
a été créé.
Ce n'était pas le sien
idée de le porter.
Je pense
s'ils ne l'avaient pas fait,
une grande partie du film
aurait échoué.
Vous savez, le temps le plus long
J'ai rêvé de...
...venant à l'étranger
et être en première ligne,
au service de mon pays,
essayer de tout obtenir
J'ai voulu...
...et je porte des collants.
À certains égards,
Captain America est
le surhomme
de l'univers Marvel
dans le sens où
c'est ce héros patriotique,
ce mec tout américain.
Mais son histoire est sans doute
pas aussi intéressant
et certainement dans le premier
Film Captain America
ce que beaucoup diraient
est l'un des plus faibles
des films MCU.
Bien que les deux
Thor et Captain America
était tombé en deçà du
énorme succès au box-office
d'Iron Man,
leur 2011
sortie suggérée
que les studios Marvel
projet audacieux
se développait en douceur.
Et ce n'était pas simplement
un engouement pour les films de super-héros -
un autre de l'été
sorties de mâts de tente,
une sortie à gros budget
pour Green Lantern de DC,
s'est avéré un critique important
et échec commercial.
Mais Marvel jouait
par ses propres règles.
Sa stratégie multi-films,
qui deviendrait connu
comme la merveille
Univers cinématographique,
vu chacun
libération individuelle
fonctionner comme un versement de
une plus grande série connexe,
avec des acteurs signés
représenter le même personnage
dans un grand
nombre de films.
Si Marvel
pourrait le retirer,
cet univers connecté
serait
un révolutionnaire
réalisation.
Et pas seulement
était la stratégie unique,
le studio était aussi
approcher le cinéma de super-héros
d'une manière fraîche.
Auparavant, l'impulsion créative
à l'origine de nombreuses adaptations
a été ramené
par des administrateurs distinctifs -
de Tim Burton
et Ang Lee
à Bryan Singer
et Christopher Nolan -
qui ont tous offert
leurs propres interprétations
du matériel source.
La vision de Marvel était
Dans les mains
du président de la production
Kevin Feige, cependant,
et les cinéastes
amené à bord
devaient servir
dans le cadre
d'un projet beaucoup plus vaste.
La plus grande épreuve
de cet ambitieux projet
est venu dans le
Printemps 2012.
Ayant établi
leurs personnages principaux
dans des films solo à succès,
Marvel Studios a apporté
ces héros ensemble
dans Les Vengeurs.
A sa sortie il s'est cassé
records au box-office dans le monde entier,
et est devenu le plus haut-
film de super-héros qui rapporte
de tous les temps.
Ils
construit film par film.
Ils sont allés
de mieux en mieux.
Comme chaque film était un succès,
ils ont commencé à construire.
Mais le plan de jeu de la construction
tous ces films disparates,
faire se rencontrer les personnages
encore une fois dans le grand blockbuster,
ça n'a jamais été fait
avant. C'est brilliant.
Et c'est offrir
l'auditoire
un niveau de cohérence
ils n'ont pas vu.
Eh bien, ils ne peuvent pas l'obtenir
n'importe où ailleurs.
Le
chose qu'ils ont faite
avec l'univers interconnecté
est ahurissant.
Le fait qu'ils aient obtenu...
que The Avengers étaient sur le film,
Je n'arrive toujours pas à y croire.
Cela fait des années qu'il...
Je ne peux toujours pas croire
ils ont réussi ça.
La première
Le film Avengers était génial.
A l'époque, je ne pense pas
Je n'avais jamais vraiment ressenti
un tel buzz au cinéma à propos de
comment cela allait fonctionner.
Nous n'étions pas sûrs d'être honnêtes
si ça allait marcher.
certainement pour les personnes
qui étaient fans de bandes dessinées,
Je pense que c'était
un bonheur absolu
pour enfin voir ces gars
partager un écran ensemble
et ils étaient plus que
la somme de leurs parties.
Alors ensemble ils étaient mieux
qu'ils ne l'étaient en tant qu'individus.
Et les Vengeurs
a même vu triompher Marvel
avec un personnage
qui avait déjà lutté
traverser
aux cinéphiles.
Comme le casting du film
ont été accueillis
comme des rockstars
lors de premières mondiales,
Parmi eux
était Mark Ruffalo,
le dernier
dans une longue lignée d'acteurs
pour incarner le Dr Bruce Banner
et son alter ego, Hulk.
Je pense que Hulk a trouvé une maison.
Vous pourriez dire tout l'arc
de l'histoire de Hulk
depuis 1962 était,
"Où appartiendra Hulk?"
Où appartenait Hulk,
surprise Surprise
était dans les films Avengers,
car il n'y avait pas que lui
monopolisant tout l'écran.
Il a vraiment joué
ces autres personnages.
L'interprétation de Mark Ruffalo de
Bruce Banner était génial.
Quand tu n'avais pas besoin de Hulk,
vous pourriez en quelque sorte le renvoyer.
Mais quand tu avais besoin de lui,
il a été très efficace.
Dr Banner...
Maintenant pourrait être un très bon moment
pour que tu te fâches.
C'est mon secret, capitaine...
Je suis toujours en colère.
Alors que l'univers Marvel
était enfin révélé
dans toute sa splendeur,
une autre série de super-héros
était prêt
dévoiler
sa dernière tranche.
Avec le public
toujours sous le choc
de l'impact
des Vengeurs,
Deux mois après
Le chevalier noir se lève
a été libéré.
Avec Christian Bale prenant
sur le manteau de la chauve-souris
pour la dernière fois,
il a affronté
contre son compatriote acteur britannique
Tom Hardy comme Bane, un
méchant moins connu de Batman
créé par Chuck Dixon
et Graham Nolan,
qui était apparu auparavant
dans Batman et Robin en 1998.
Bane s'en sort beaucoup mieux
dans Dark Knight Rises
qu'il ne l'a fait dans
Batman et Robin.
Ce n'est pas un homme de main stupide.
Ils lui présentent
en tant que cerveau.
Ils le présentent comme un dur à cuire
qui est l'un des
les choses les plus importantes.
Il est intelligent et c'est un dur à cuire.
Fléau!
Ne restons pas debout
en cérémonie ici...
...M. Wayne.
La patience a un coût
vous votre force.
La victoire vous a vaincu.
Ils lui ont fait
un nom familier.
Tout le monde sait
qui il est maintenant,
que je suis encore
me prendre la tête.
Tu connais Graham Nolan
et je suis comme, wow.
Vous savez, nous venons d'arriver
avec une idée folle,
et le voici
dans les jouets, dans les porte-clés
et pyjama et Halloween
costumes, tout.
Sorti en juillet 2012,
avec un méchant inconnu
et la performance de Heath Ledger
comme le Joker encore frais
dans la mémoire des cinéphiles,
ce dernier chapitre de
La trilogie de Christopher Nolan
avait beaucoup à
être à la hauteur de...
Il y a
le problème que le Joker
était un tel impact
présence dans The Dark Knight
que vous allez inévitablement
manquer ce côté dans le prochain film.
Tu es manifestement un peu
envie de le revoir.
Et qui sait,
si les choses n'avaient pas marché
ils l'ont fait avec Heath Ledger,
qui sait ce qui aurait
s'est passé dans le troisième film.
Mais une des choses
J'aime vraiment ça,
c'est l'un d'eux
films de super-héros rares,
que nous venons de
ne reverra peut-être jamais,
qu'en fait
a une fin.
Il a une netteté,
fin enveloppée
que tu peux ressentir
c'était là que ça allait
de Batman Begins.
En fait, vous obtenez tout à fait
une récompense émotionnelle, je pense.
Je ne me suis jamais soucié de qui tu étais.
Alors tu avais raison.
Les gens ne devraient-ils pas savoir
le héros qui les a sauvés ?
Un héros peut être n'importe qui.
Même un homme
qui fait quelque chose
aussi simple que rassurant
comme mettre un manteau
autour des épaules d'un jeune garçon
pour lui faire savoir
le monde n'était pas fini.
Bruce Wayne.
Nolan est resté fidèle à ses armes
et a fait ce qu'il
voulait faire.
Il a fait un arc réussi,
l'arc qu'il voulait raconter.
C'était cohérent,
ça avait l'air super.
Même si comme
un autonome,
je ne pense pas que ce soit aussi fort
comme les deux autres films.
En ensemble,
Je pense que ça va absolument
tenir tête à la
l'épreuve du temps.
A la suite de ces
deux milliards de dollars
mastodontes grossiers,
super-héros
a conquis le monde.
La culture de la bande dessinée pleinement
a explosé dans le courant dominant,
les marchandises ont afflué
tous les magasins imaginables,
convention
la fréquentation a grimpé en flèche
et personne n'avait
cacher sa passion
comme un plaisir coupable
plus.
Comme les X-Men et Spider-Man
la série a vu redémarrer
qui cherchait à faire revivre
ces franchises
après impopulaire
troisième tranche,
La cinématique des studios Marvel
sortie alimentée toujours en avant.
Avec Iron Man 3,
Thor: Le Monde des Ténèbres
et Captain America :
Soldat d'Hiver
tout s'ouvrant sur
éloge critique
et de plus en plus
les retours au box-office,
les projecteurs sont bientôt tombés
sur Kevin Feige.
Comme le succès de la
univers interconnecté
est devenu jamais
plus apparent,
la presse a célébré
le cerveau
derrière le rideau.
Il est comme
le Steve Jobs du cinéma.
Et je pense que l'histoire va
être très gentil avec ce gars,
quand tu as la capacité
revenir sur ce qu'il a fait
dans son intégralité car
nous sommes toujours au milieu.
Je ne pense pas que le public
peut vraiment apprécier
la magnitude
de ce que ce type a construit.
C'est stupéfiant.
Avec bande dessinée
personnages du livre
dominateur
la culture populaire,
en 2013 Warner Brothers
et DC a cherché à revivre
l'original
super-héros à succès.
Avec une histoire de
l'équipe Batman Begins
de Christophe Nolan
et David S. Goyer,
réalisateur Zach Snyder
Derrière la caméra
et le jeune acteur britannique Henry
Cavill dans le rôle principal,
Man of Steel a cherché à apporter
Superman dans l'ère moderne.
Et malgré certains
réactions négatives,
ses performances commerciales
Warner convaincu
aller de l'avant
avec des plans pour une suite.
Pourtant le succès de
Les Vengeurs
et de Marvel
univers interconnecté
avait envoyé des ondes de choc
à travers l'industrie cinématographique,
et des franchises à succès conventionnelles
ne semblait plus si attrayant.
Avec chrétien
Chevalier noir de Bale
encore frais
dans la mémoire du public,
Warners a néanmoins regardé
apporter le caractère
dans le monde de
Homme d'acier,
et unBatman contre Superman
le projet a été rapidement annoncé
comme le prochain
dans une série de films
qui inclurait le grand écran
sorties pour Wonder Woman,
Aquaman et les autres membres
de la Justice League de DC.
Et sans Kevin Feige
Tirer les ficelles
et assurer la cohérence,
le studio avait l'air
au réalisateur Zack Snyder
conduire le
vision créative
pour ça
univers interconnecté.
Le casting de Ben Affleck
en tant que nouveau Caped Crusader
et présentant Gal Gadot
comme premier grand écran
Wonder Woman,
à sa sortie, Batman vs
Superman : L'aube de la justice
essuyé des tirs de
aussi bien le public que les critiques.
Lorsque vous
regarde les films DC,
certainement il y a beaucoup de
Zack Snyder en fait partie.
Zack Snyder,
qui a réalisé Watchmen,
le premier vrai nihiliste
affrontez des super-héros -
super-héros qui sont confrontés
sans gagner,
la situation impossible à gagner.
Avec Man of Steel et Batman
contre Superman L'Aube de la Justice
ces films sont tombés
une route sombre
parce que nous ne croyons pas
chez les héros.
La prochaine fois qu'ils brillent
ta lumière dans le ciel
n'y allez pas.
La chauve-souris est morte, enterrée.
Considérez cette miséricorde.
Dites-moi...
Vous saignez ?
j'ai voulu
voir Batman et Superman
combat depuis que je suis tout petit.
Ce est tellement cool.
J'aurais dû devenir fou
sur ce film.
Mais j'ai l'impression
c'était juste trop traité.
Je pense que nous sommes partis
trop loin avec le graveleux.
je pense qu'il n'y en avait pas
plaisir à propos de ce film.
C'était juste comme
Superman était déprimé
et Batman était en colère
puis ils se sont battus.
Puis Wonder Woman
arrive et elle est super.
Ensuite, nous sommes tous en colère à nouveau
et tout le monde est déprimé.
C'est juste tout noir
et c'est triste.
Aube
de la justice est un mauvais film
et une partie de la raison
c'est un mauvais film
est à cause de la façon dont
massivement ça trahit
à la fois Batman et Superman,
les faisant tous les deux
en idiots pétulants absolus.
Ils sont tous les deux violents
et égoïste et stupide.
Et en fait c'est complètement
ruine aussi Lois Lane
et fait d'elle une
terrible demoiselle en détresse
qui est une responsabilité complète
pour tout le film.
C'était comme une trahison totale
de ces personnages qui
nous aimions depuis si longtemps
et un énorme malentendu.
Alors que les DC
tenter de lancer un rival
à l'univers cinématographique de Marvel
s'est avéré extrêmement diviseur,
ailleurs des films de super-héros
allaient
de mieux en mieux
et leur stock dans
l'industrie cinématographique au sens large
continué à monter.
Un bien rafraîchi
Franchise X-Men
a vu le réalisateur Bryan Singer
retourner à la barre
et combiner
ses héros originaux
avec un nouveau casting plus jeune
dans Days of Future Past,
qui devint rapidement
le plus commercialement
film à succès de la série.
Autre part,
Marvel Studios ressemblait à
ça ne pouvait pas faire de mal,
et aux côtés d'un deuxième
sortie pour The Avengers,
de nouveaux films sont apparus
ça rapportait encore moins
personnages familiers
du passé de l'éditeur
à un public mondial.
Avec les gardiens
de la Galaxie
Marvel a montré, nous pouvons
faire un milliard avec les gens
que même les fans de bandes dessinées
ne savent même pas qui ils sont.
Si vous parlez de super-héros
ça n'aurait jamais dû marcher
n'aurait jamais dû être
capable de travailler... Ant-Man.
Quel est le seul film
ça ne marchera jamais ?
L'homme fourmi.
Et c'était super.
À certains égards
Ant-Man est le baiser triomphal
que Marvel peut dire,
"Nous l'avons fait."
Qu'on peut même s'en sortir
avec un film Ant-Man.
Pendant si longtemps ce serait
une blague. C'était une blague.
Verrons-nous jamais
un film Ant-Man ?
Verrons-nous même
une bande dessinée Ant-Man à nouveau?
Le fait que Marvel
a pu retirer ça
dans un film à succès
encore un bon casting...
C'était la manière de Marvel
de dire,
on peut s'en sortir
avec n'importe quoi.
Et dans le
années précédentes,
l'atelier a continué
apporter sa touche Midas
aux deux suites
et de nouveaux projets,
avec Docteur Strange
fait ses débuts au cinéma
et Spider-Man a finalement apporté
dans l'univers Marvel.
Ailleurs les X-Men
franchise agrandie,
avec deux films révolutionnaires
destiné à un public adulte.
Deadpool mélangé extrême
violence avec comédie acerbe
et est devenu un
sensation globale,
tandis que Logan appartenait à Hugh Jackman
chant du cygne comme Wolverine,
le sombre dernier chapitre
pour le personnage
qui avait lancé
sa carrière.
Ayant dominé populaire
culture depuis plus d'une décennie,
à la suite de
ces films,
adaptations de bandes dessinées encore
offert de nouvelles opportunités
pour les deux studios
et les cinéphiles.
Et ce n'était nulle part
plus apparent
que dans
deux films révolutionnaires
publié par DC et Marvel
dans un délai de 12 mois.
Wonder Woman a finalement donné
ce personnage de 75 ans
un film à elle,
avec Patty Jenkins
la toute première femme
diriger un studio américain
film de super-héros.
La panthère noire de Marvel,
d'autre part,
a donné à Stan Lee et Jack Kirby
super-héros africain historique
un véhicule solo historique.
Directeurs de studio
dans le passé aurait dit,
"Nous ne pouvons pas faire un film dirigé par une femme
car il ne se vendra pas.
Nous ne pouvons pas faire un film mené
par une personne de couleur,
ou les personnes de couleur
être le casting prédominant
car il ne se vendra pas.
Eh bien, vous vous trompez.
Les gens aiment Wonder Woman.
Vous n'avez pas à être
une fille pour aimer Wonder Woman.
Tout le monde aime
Wonder Woman.
Je pense que ça a pris tellement de temps
obtenir Wonder Woman
sur grand écran,
parce que tout le monde avait peur
faire un film de super-héros féminin
et tu brandis des films comme
Catwoman et Elektra
et dis,
« Ah bon, c'est ça...
parce que les femmes
ne peuvent pas être des super-héros."
Eh bien, non, ils doivent être
dans de bons films.
Je sais quand Gal
Gadot a été choisi
les gens étaient
un peu inquiet.
"Oh, eh bien, elle ne le fait pas
regarde par-là."
Merde ça.
Elle était fantastique.
C'était
extrêmement important
et extrêmement significatif
comme un film.
C'est ridicule, très honnêtement,
que nous avons eu
ces univers depuis,
Eh bien, même si nous ne faisons que parler
à propos de MCU et DC c'est 2008.
Ça fait dix ans qu'on n'a pas
a obtenu une seule femme principale.
Nous avons secondaire
personnages autour.
Nous avons Black Widow
qui est incroyable
interprétée par Scarlett Johansson,
l'un des plus connus,
actrices bancables
dans le monde
et elle ne peut pas obtenir
son propre film.
C'est de la folie absolue.
Wonder Woman qui sort,
être dirigé par une femme
avoir un très fort
casting de femmes de soutien
était un très
chose importante.
Battement CC
Émerveillez-vous au coup de poing
en termes d'obtention d'une femelle
super-héros leur premier film.
Alors évidemment Marvel a
sortir avec Black Panther
et je pense que c'est énormément
grand moment culturel
avoir ce film dirigé par
les gens de couleur installés en Afrique,
et le film traite
avec des problèmes de race de front.
Ce n'est pas
juste que cela est conduit
par un noir. Le casting
est majoritairement noir.
Et c'est en fait
vraiment révolutionnaire.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
nous avons vu dans cet univers.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous avons vu
dans n'importe quel univers de super-héros
ou même en fait dans n'importe quel
univers à succès massif.
C'est donc révolutionnaire
et en lui donnant
à Ryan Coogler,
qui est un réalisateur fantastique,
qui avait fait Fruitvale
Gare et credo,
tous les deux avec Michael
B.Jordanie,
et il semble lui donner
un règne assez libre
raconter l'histoire
qu'il voulait dire,
qu'est-ce que tu as en fait
est très important,
très politique,
vraiment édifiant,
film très révolutionnaire
ça donne encore l'impression
un film Marvel.
Pour utiliser le MCU pour être
capable de parler de problèmes
que nous ne verrions probablement pas
dans les multiplexes est incroyable.
Comme l'énormité
de Black Panther
Importance culturelle
et succès commercial
a prouvé,
les super-héros restent
non seulement populaire
mais extrêmement influent.
Avec un public mondial toujours
être présenté aux personnages
qui ont existé dans les comics
monde depuis un demi-siècle,
la richesse des héros
et histoires
encore à faire la transition
de la page à l'écran
suggère que
cette popularité durera.
Et bien que la proéminence
de ces icônes
est à son point culminant
depuis leur création,
la bande dessinée elle-même
a retenu
sa réputation de spécialiste.
Ne jamais revenir à
son pic de vente des années 1990,
que la presse écrite
devient moins pertinent
à notre époque moderne,
la forme d'art qui a lancé
ce phénomène mondial
reste largement ignoré.
En ce qui concerne
comment les bandes dessinées étaient considérées
je ne pense pas qu'ils l'étaient
considéré comme différent.
Soit vous les aimez
ou vous ne les aimez pas.
Beaucoup de gens
n'aime tout simplement pas les bandes dessinées.
Et il y a heureusement des gens
qui les aiment beaucoup.